everybody it is Monday the first day of
spring
the background is updated the rabbits
are out the Ducks are out it's a
beautiful spring day
it's exciting I love spring come on who
doesn't love spring it's spring time
and today
uh very happy to be here with you guys
happy Monday of course
we've got a great show planned I myself
spent the whole weekend in The Slammer
my weekend was terrible
as you can see by the title
um
I got trashed on Friday
and I well I'll talk more about it later
in the show
because it's
it's just hard to talk it's just a
downer and not I don't want to bring the
show down at the start of the show so
we'll talk about it then
but in other news and nice news good
news guess what I got unbanned on Tick
Tock let's [__] go
can you believe it
they admit they said there is no
violation with peace and love and you
know who did I got to give a shout out
to my girl Monet
foreign
it is in my goddamn home she was on the
podcast the other day she um
is awesome what's her full what's her
last name it was mix something McMichael
oh yeah McMichael Monet Mick Michael who
[Music]
she came through for me dude
she gave me a contact at Tick Tock I
wrote them they expedited it and here I
am back Tick Tock is my home I'm not
live because I'm pretty sure I would
just get permanently banned again I mean
that's just not fair
in fact my first video back on ticked up
was me complaining about it you guys
want to watch it
real fast
yeah I was captivating I've watched
again
it's kind of long so if you lose any
attention
I built something in there for
hey guys I have noticed that I was
recently permanently banned on Tick Tock
and now that I'm back I do want to say
that I think it really underlies a
serious problem that we're having here
on Tick Tock that people can just be
removed for no reason and this
oh hold on
and especially when Tick Tock is being
talked about you know being removed by
the government I think we're supposed to
remember that that's my full attention
it's important to give people their due
diligence before completely Banning them
because
right you know it's important that's we
uh
say it like it is so I am back on Tick
Tock with peace and love
yes sir yes ma'am very glad to be back
I'll be back to enjoy the couple days
left before it gets permanently uh
banned by the president how about that
who's gonna get banned now at first
what do you guys think about that whole
Tick Tock band thing I was listen I was
listening to a story about it today
it seems to me
I do understand from a perspective the
concern the biggest concern I see is
that
they can manipulate the content that
people see to promote like conspiracy
theories or stuff like that like I could
see that really influencing people and
people are so [__] dumb they do get
influenced I mean we saw that on YouTube
when the algorithm was pushing people to
like
uh
conspiracy thinking and white supremacy
and so if China wanted to they
definitely could do that let's be honest
so I guess that is a big concern but
on the other hand
you know that America just wants to own
the social media game
it's like China got this big social
media Goliath and it's like man what the
[__] hell nah
that's our that's our business we the
ones that sell data
the other thing is our business too
propaganda
what
what are you talking about dude
our government has never lied show me
one instance of our government lying
I'll wait ladies and gentlemen we got
them
yeah you're right it's like if you want
data all you got to do is go to Facebook
and be like hey Cambridge and analytica
can I [__] like they're already doing
it um
yeah exactly but on the other hand it's
like okay China then why don't you let
America what do you let Chinese people
use Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
if you're so cool without owning social
media companies then because none of
that [__] you can even use there so it's
like what's up I mean that is that's a
fair point
yeah I was thinking that today it's like
they don't let anyone there use the
American social media so [__] them you
know yeah I mean I think a [__] ton of
people do because I'm pretty certain
it's uh very easy to get around
I think if you just use a VPN or
whatever
um you can get around their firewalls so
would that be true of tick tock if they
banned it here
well because it's an app I guess maybe
people would probably figure out a way
to do it
the app probably wouldn't work anymore
but I genuinely don't through a browser
you could probably still access it
right that doesn't sound like it'll
that'll it'll die there's people aren't
going to be on their browser yeah but
you know I'll I'll still be able to post
on the podcast account from Sweden yeah
there you go there we go you can smuggle
it out of the country for us smuggle our
tick tocks yeah it's such [__]
though it's like I don't know to me it's
like a really ugly kind of move where
it's like
you're not opening business to the world
we're closing business we're saying okay
China we can't do this with you we can't
do business with you anymore and then
it's like we want to shrink back into
our caves and not talk to any other
people countries
it's not good it's not a good thing
you know
that's like oh we get our flat we if you
know China delivers us flour what if
they're pushing putting like a cyanide
in our flower
they could
no more Chinese flour Dan
they're put you know
they make our computer chips couldn't
they [__] with that
where's all the my this phone was made
in China
couldn't they put a bug in the system
probably they wanted to
so I'm saying
where's the line drawn
tick tock's my [__] home to be honest
I just want Ryan Kavanaugh out of
business if if he wasn't in the equation
I'd be like gung-ho I'd be like [__]
Tick Tock ban them
I'm just trying to plead the case
because I need him to go bankrupt
this is like um this is like debate
class when you have to defend something
you know is [__] up and wrong right
thank you yeah Tick Tock should be
probably banned
but let's not say that because drive
angry I need the worst for Ryan
Kavanaugh
you know but
the [__] was that oh the ball
yeah
oh speaking of the bowl
um
this is interesting hmm
did we I think we confirmed it right
with Bryce
we confirmed it
Bryce Hall
Ryan Cavanaugh's Golden Boy next week is
coming next week
yes sir
dude I wonder if Kavanaugh's gonna see
this and try to tell him not to come I
you know what one part of me was like I
don't want to say it publicly because
Kavanaugh is going to see it but on the
other hand I feel like this is
interesting test to put out there to see
like is Kavanaugh gonna go to make Bryce
cancel now
and Bryce is Bryce is a cool dude he's
not someone who gets you get to tell who
and who he can't talk to because Bryce
is a real alpha dog bro
and Cav cab who we know is a beta
betas don't tell Alphas what to do
period
get in the pack
[Music]
um
let me just confirm with Bryce
it's for next week it's replies no sorry
I can't do it
he's like I'm what yeah I just wanna
because that would be interesting right
I want to know
yeah the Kavanaugh
Saga is still
is still charging forward apparently on
on Wikipedia there is still a war being
fought over Ryan Kavanaugh's Wikipedia
page which is just so
funny to me
um by the way Wikipedia editors don't
[__] around dude they are good very
seriously and they they don't get paid
right these people are just love for the
game Love of the Game well of course I
pay them according to Ryan Kavanaugh I
don't for the record I don't even know
who these people are I know ride doesn't
believe that but that's how strong the
family is he had a bunch of sock puppets
though I don't know if he was paying
them but that that's what's in that's
right that's in this uh in the new one
there is actually no there's someone who
straight up admits they have to disclose
it I guess he goes yes I must disclose I
am a close personal associate of Ryan
I'm his PR manager he's got he's got his
PR manager so embarrassing I gotta pull
it up
mikasu says I just beat cancer thank you
Ethan eel and the crew for being wow for
me through some bad times oh yeah
that's everything good [__] congrats
dude man that's awesome [__] love that
for you bro
or sis
so here it is
yes so it's the same guy's thrust and
pop Pokey 35. dude these guys are
[__] Warriors in the trench man right
now there's just this Great Divide you
know there's a fight
hmm yeah and um
they really are and they're just
fighting for truth that's it you know
they're not they don't have an
allegiance they're not
they're not like doing anything but
telling the truth about you uh Ryan
so here's some of the edit notes let's
see
the wick of me Wikimedia foundation in
terms of use requires that editors
disclose their employer client and
affiliation
with respect to any paid contributions
and then there's this user uh min
premuzy
has been paid by unknown
their editing has included contributions
to this article the user has been banned
and may therefore be reverted on site
Swanky has been paid by a a b tack
hmm
their editing has included contributions
to this article this user has been
banned and therefore may be reverted on
site what article are we talking about
is it it's just his Wikipedia page yeah
holy [__] to Bloodbath
the real Serena Joy has been paid by
unknown their editing has included
contributions you skipped the the most
important one oh Rex 2022 has been paid
by Ryan Cavanaugh declared here
[Music]
oh there's another one chesterb has been
paid by Quadra promotions on behalf of
Ryan Kavanaugh declared here
[Music]
this man is in the presence Wikipedia
ain't no [__] joke
and even to this day though to be honest
with you Ryan Kavanaugh
if you type your name it's Wikipedia at
our website
so we are informing the masses
have an inappropriate relationship
you [__] loser
you [__] tackling dude
podcast host you [__] like thunder just
crashed because you [__] you
put this toy podcast
laughs
just the truth though yeah there's
nothing underhanded going on here the
truth is being shared and people are
listening you know
the truth rings true and free and that's
that's why people listen so okay
interesting so there's two people of
like five who have been disclosed
Associates here let's go over so here's
Chester B
um
let's see hello fellow wikipedians I'm a
writer so I decided it would be a good
idea to become a Wikipedia editor
I still love playing chess okay nobody
cares I'm addicted to four-way chess bro
who cares
so now it says um
the user in accordance with Wikimedia
Foundation discloses they have been paid
by boho Beauty
so they're just uh shows the highlighted
ones yeah but all the other ones so
they're they this they do paid work yep
and you go down this user in accordance
with the Wikimedia terms discloses they
have been paid by Quadra promotions on
behalf of Ryan Kavanaugh for all their
contributions Wikipedia are these guys
just like real professionals I think and
they're not they're like I'll do the
work but I have to disclose what who for
right so this I think this is just a
real one here
here's another one the other one was uh
I
I don't I see the username but it says I
hereby disclose my connection oh it's
down below Rex 20 okay yeah
2022. hey hereby disclosed by a close
connection he's clear close they're in
the same room
with the subject of this page Ryan
Kavanaugh I'm a PR manager to my boss
Ryan
stupid I don't know why you had to
disclose that other than to embarrass
your boss you're not even a Wikipedia
editor
he's like yeah I just want to [__] yeah
my boss [__] made me do this he's
[__] annoying
my boss he made me do this [__]
I
[__] Ryan camera you know what it
probably is Ryan probably did finally
learn his lesson because he was himself
secretly editing we we think right no we
know we like conclusively no no no I
think it's
I remember I don't want to say a hundred
percent because of course you know he's
already sued me three times
before but what I allegedly for
he lost that one
on page 14
. so um
[Music]
there was like five users and I think
the users were accusing they're like
you're Ryan Kavanaugh and I think one of
the comments he was like referring to
the page as his page
so I don't know if it was him 100 but
but there was compelling evidence yeah
that he was doing it himself
but anyways he probably got banned
enough because I remember he got into
the giant war with thrust and lost yeah
yeah yeah but he's like you gotta edit
it but you know you have to disclose
this or you're just gonna get banned
yeah so by the way if you guys want to
go ahead and type Ryan Cavanaugh it's
always a good opportunity for you to go
to Google
or Bing whatever you use type in his
name this is important because you want
to if you misspell it
the search engine will correct you
so type it push enter and then click
the website
you know how Bing is incorporating the
the chat GPT or whatever I wonder if
enough people search for
this website on Bing if it'll get into
the algorithm and all questions about
Kavanaugh will start doing well hold on
be answered with a mention of the
website did Bing
oh it's up there on Bank two do they
have the bot is not public yet I think
it's I think it's uh yeah invite status
right now but it sounds really
interesting though being one Ryan
Kavanaugh
uh now it's the same results second
second result that's great same results
very cool
yeah
yeah interesting
one and two
search results Ryan Kavanaugh H3 Ryan
Cavanaugh Ethan Klein Ryan Cavanaugh
versus Ethan Klein it's a toy podcast
what can you say it just you know
although I have to say Bing is pretty
dumb they go you may want to explore
Brett Kavanaugh it's like idiot
stupid we drank beer it's like stupid
ass dumb search engine and having some
beers with friends oh people saying the
website's uh got
overloaded
oh no no yeah I'm seeing people in the
chat I think so many people are gone
it might be because it's like hasn't
been used to us much lately so they
did we just get DDOS from Brian
Kavanaugh from our own family I mean
maybe well so just just you know put in
the effort to get on the website yeah
and go back later and you know browse it
maybe keep it open uh as well
I mean if this website is up or not it
doesn't really matter Google doesn't
care just click on it anyway that's what
counts
yeah
yeah but if you go to his Wikipedia page
I am I haven't checked in on the
with the uh view let's see history let's
see if it what's the bloodbath going on
back here
um throws there he is today there's my
boy you're the [__] King
this guy is such a legend
you gotta love his dedication of Truth
and justice
so today's the 20th so just today
there's been one two three four five
edits yesterday there was four edits but
this is
still football he's there too yeah
and they're editing is legal issues
section too
let's see um there's this user woodrar
said
removing section Source suppress release
promotion article this content does not
involve the editorial staff they're just
they're trying to whitewash it and then
the rest goes uh-uh he goes no both the
LA weekly and Village Voice articles
which were written by the same author
are comically biased towards the subject
and may or may not have been written and
published for compensation
removed 3500 Words king
he says this [__] is comically biased
well it's probably we we saw one of
those right that was very clearly just
like a paid article can I open it can I
see what article they're talking about
uh yeah um I forget where to click
though because everything like the days
maybe
yeah maybe yeah the date
the date yeah
yeah there you go so this is the version
but how I want to see the Articles find
where they're talking about the article
how do I [__] find it right I can
search for it yeah just [__] yeah it's
like God damn
it's like goddamn
but there is there is a war being fought
and you know right now there's just this
Great Divide you know there's a fight
right
absolutely
[Music]
here you can see this is nice you can
see the table of contents
and he should be happy because in a
sense this is a really comprehensive
like look out [__] fat this Wikipedia
is and that doesn't happen for a lot of
people unless they're important
for example early life
to read an excerpt uh oh it's the
article that I was talking about which
yes removed it which one here I'm gonna
look at you right now
the one where uh oh I just sent it to
our mod by accident hold on Kavanaugh
attended use he's going to use that as
evidence bro
foreign
I can't wait for him to like somehow try
to like force Discovery to see if I'm
paying thrust and for poking it's just
not I'm just not I don't even know the
[__] they are
okay so here's the article let's see
[Music]
oh la weekly yeah this is like straight
up like
they have a cannabis uh written in
partnership with uh
partnership wait it was a different name
before
right it was like the same article I
remember we went down this whole rabbit
hole and it was like we weren't sure if
it was a real person
oh this bro are you serious is that why
he's writing this [__] Brian Kavanaugh
prominent Hollywood producer the
philanthropist has won a significant
legal Victory against popular YouTuber
either Clyde that's
so silly
could this be the end of the
controversial podcaster
what the [__] this was written by a
goddamn AI dude
right okay yeah cam just linked the
other one though it was in tech times
here's the other article this is the one
that we talked about on the show very
similar sentiment probably
uh what a [__] look I want to
speculate on uh
who is sponsoring this well
sure I can't imagine many people would
be motivated to write these kinds of
Articles and then to link them to his
Wikipedia page but you know I'm not here
to to put blame on anyone yeah well no
worries thrust has it covered
well he's Young
again I just love his Wikipedia page
it's like you can't even get through a
single section without just
brutal takedowns like even just in the
intro after relativity filed for
bankruptcy he stepped down a CO and
faced several lawsuits
early life he attended UC Santa Barbara
UCLA but dropped out in 2012 Kavanaugh
threatened the New York the New Yorker
with legal action for its reporting on
him including that reports that he
dropped out of University Kavanaugh said
he was an official graduate of UCLA and
rolled in the PHD program the New
Yorkers stood by its reporting
it's like this man is just a degenerate
[__] loser like at every turn of his
life
you're a loser anyway that's just a
little update you know I I talked about
Ryan Kavanaugh enough on this show yeah
but the wars are still happening my
friend Wikipedia is a no joke No Joke
Man
we shall fight in the street
we shall fight in the land we shall
fight on Wikipedia we shall fight on
Google
we shall
fights
we will sit in the corner and watch our
wife get [__]
not that there's anything wrong with
that of course
okay all right all right
enough
thank you
so that's still going on
nothing wrong with being a cop you know
I'm not the one that invented that as an
insult
if that's what you're into God bless bro
you know what I mean I'm not I'm not
here to shame anybody for their
for their interests it never
Douglas thank you for the 10 gifted
Legend
Lauren love the spring background the
button peeking into the frame really
adds a foreboding flavor couldn't agree
more with you uh Lauren oh speaking of
the button there's just been an an
absolute Renaissance
a fan made button uh standby screens
thank you everybody for the really
incredible art we have all of these
basically in rotation right if I slam
the button
uh no not yet oh not yet
we have a bunch of them in rotation but
there was a ton this weekend that needs
to be added still does this include the
ones that we had on rotation that we
haven't shown
the album yes
so here's all the great ones we'll be
right back Looney Tunes even
we'll be right back that's fantastic
well it's a little Darth Vader that
doesn't fit so well
I look because it's just me as Uncle
Fester which is kind of the same as
Darth Vader
I don't know if I really understand that
one like I like it but like no it
doesn't make sense in my opinion like
that scene
I don't know we'll be right back Dan is
Luke
and all right that's what I was
wondering if oh maybe Luke says I'll be
right back for you no no it's I think
it's Vader tells me you were right you
were right oh thank you Luke yeah I
guess I'm I'm Luke and I hit the button
and that's you
leave without me you were right leave me
here leave me here
technical difficulties please stand by
this one's great fun little kind of just
like a Steven Universe kind of thing I
don't know
Ethan went against the family we'll be
right back how dare you that's not true
at all
more like I was intercepted by the
conciliers
they're accepted by the concierge yeah
we can't I didn't go against the family
I don't like that you say the concierge
the concierge Council lady making me
forget it yeah
counselor is stepped in the concierge
[Laughter]
please stand by Ethan slipped again
please
yikes I like that drawing I love it
that's that's literally what happened at
Tom Segura maybe that's maybe they
intentionally drew it like that oh this
is brand new it's got Ila's long
pigtails yeah yeah nice
please stand by it's me and a B I like
that bomb Oh no Gotham is in danger
that's awesome that's cool the H3
podcast technical difficulties brought
to you by Asian Productions that's fun
lots of Looney Tunes is in there
please stand by this is good
Jay Leno of course
whoa
at least stand by remain calm that's
sick
slamming that button please stand by we
are under attack that's awesome
sneaker jerking off
as moduck or whatever the [__] that
character says love is the [__] uh I
love that it's awesome dude [__]
[__] bro [__] [__] yo they're
really talented I love their art style
yeah that's cool yeah it's really cool
our here's their name our x z a
something DX
it's covered by the The Matrix letters
technical difficulties we'll be right
back that one's pretty awesome too I
wish this thing moved around that would
make it worth it
ah I will say that these this is a video
too on Loop so if you want to submit
animations feel free too all right there
it is I like that one a lot nothing more
than 15 seconds though this one
technical difficult it looks really sick
this one oh boy big oh boy
somebody stopped me that I like that I
like
that's very powerful
Joker brain moment stand by please bruh
that I like I like
very much
sure we'll be right back okay
click that we'll be right back
this is oh no
it's the uh
I would love if that one was animated
the head it's the uh
clay I see that with like analog like
static lines
our apologies we thought it was cake
we'll be right back
ow mind erasing in progress that's
awesome
please stand this one I
this one I can't say I totally got yeah
I don't think we'll
get it I mean I get it it's just what
did I do what did I do that
you don't want to hear about 9 11. I do
think we want to include that looks
alarmingly good on osama's face
like that that's for sure that's true
yeah that's like a perfect Photoshop
oops we'll be right back a wonderful
this one was great but there's two
problems with this one one they use the
flock of face but more importantly they
left out cam yeah what else is new oh no
no no no no no
um
when you add cam because I really like
it will not be the other one without Cam
that's not why you don't want to use it
yeah I think we could probably get away
with using it Ethan did a boo-boo beer I
love this one this one is so fun
there it is so there it is there's lots
of passion around the button
you know
it's great it's already paying off huh
there was a moment we removed from
Friday
that was I'm really glad got removed
dancing you don't well nothing happened
it just
why are you making that face so I could
talk about it it's gone bro
it worked I'm saying the button worked
cool if I speak I am in big trouble
in Victoria I'm not gonna say what
happened
I don't understand this to this um
tiptoeing
the button works that's the point we're
celebrating it
just saying just saying
all right
so let's see here
Jimmy Lee's about to call in at two as
you guys may or may not know Jimmy is in
Los Angeles right now
a little old-timey getting a little old
timey
and um
I proposition Jimmy he's been on all of
us he wants to come in
and be on the podcast
but as you guys know there's kind of a
low threshold oh they updated it with
Cam so we give some credit here to uh
yeah
they do that so fast so I just saw it in
chat and I went to the original post and
I scrolled down and I found it they
responded in a comment because they
honored YouTube very nice thank you very
much love it
yeah so as you guys know there's kind of
a low threshold for Jimmy tolerance
these days on the show
and we kind of gave him we said like
once every six months was kind of the
quota we gave him
and so
well he's in LA and he says I want to
come on the show so I said okay Jamie
I'll give you a chance and so here's
what we're gonna do he's gonna call in
at two o'clock he's going to plead
his case
and then at the end of that
we'll all take a vote as a community
and decide if he can come into the
studio on Wednesday chocolate mocha you
know colored cream yeah they're all
different flavors I leave it to the
people I am I'm only a man of the people
like the emperor like the Emperor
Palpatine or whoever was from
Gladiator
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I think that was him
I nailed it unlike him I do not want to
[__] my sister
unlike him yeah that's right the one
difference between us what's your
argument
I just don't want to [__] my sister dude
I mean Prager it's not that complicated
so um I leave it to everybody but what's
interesting leading up to this actually
is that Jimmy has been
tearing up Los Angeles there's been a
tons of posts of people who have ran
into him
him getting kicked out of restaurants
creating fomo all over the place and I
do feel as if he's become kind of a
pseudo celebrity out especially out here
in L.A everybody like people are
stopping and I'm saying hi all the time
it's kind of like he's living his dream
out here isn't it
I mean yes kind of sorta but
no I'm I'm happy for him on that but
there's a lot of things that are set up
um with fomo with fans
he frames it a certain way so
let's go ahead as we lead up to
as we lead up to the call with Jimmy I
want to show you some of my favorite
moments apparently he said he spent over
twenty thousand dollars on this trip
Hotel crew he's got he has three people
with him all all uh all the time right
yeah limo limo you know you know he's Mr
Hollywood he should move here he should
[__] leave his family in New Jersey
and I can't afford it his kids are old
enough
I got a paper to colleges I can't afford
it
you could have but he can afford to fly
out here for on like a for the midlife
trip every couple months the end of the
life crisis never stops he he has a he
has a end life end of life crisis fund
end of life
sounds like he's on hospice care last
quarter last quarter
the last quarter because we all know you
know he's pushing pushing 85 and you
know he's a 90s kid he's got plenty of
time yeah man he's good like me he was
20. you never Rugrats uh yeah he was 25
uh in 1993. how old do we actually think
he is he's sick we know no he's older
than that he's in his 70s I think no
he's mid 60s
no I think he's older order early 70s in
my opinion yeah he's too spry
well we he could resolve this by sending
his license to Zach which he said he
would he won't do it and then when I'll
ask him again he'll say don't push
I love him I'm sorry guys I just do
oh we know and then we I better we talk
enough about him on the show so here's
Jimmy Lee uh sightings
here he is this guy said he was getting
kicked out of a restaurant what happened
[Music]
how many people he's got with him what
it the [__] that's like one two three
four five six is it six people with him
yeah holy [__] that's why you know
people see that whole camera crew so
like oh this guy's gotta be someone sure
who else would waste that much money
six people
this gotta be the pr girl there's
another mouse Saddle Ranch get two
camera people the security
we need another fomo place
[Laughter]
you know we've created a monster kind of
this man is out there doing this no we
Dan you're here you're just following
orders don't say you just talked about
how that's not an excuse you're not
getting out of this hell no well he also
I noted like he posted he'll post memes
on his Instagram or whoever the [__]
will
um
of just things that are related to the
show like memes on the show that I know
he has no idea what the [__] they are
yeah we definitely established that yeah
so he like posted a Chevrolet meme she
doesn't know what the [__] that is
that's what keemstar calls Chernobyl oh
of course not of course he doesn't do of
course not
um let's see my parents are in Los
Angeles look at this celebrity that they
ran into from the subreddit Jimmy Lee
[__] gave him some old-timey
treatment at the table
and they took a photo with him this man
is he is terrorizing the entire city of
Los Angeles he's in Hollywood he's in
Venice nobody's safe
the camera's right in their face they're
just trying to enjoy a meal hey hey lady
pretty looking pretty fat there
ugly
they're just eating like french fries
hey tubby
oh [__] me
Jimmy was back at Pink's creating fomo
as we know he loves pinks his name is on
the wall
guys couple kids come here hon your kids
Jamie of course live to 20 people on
tick tock
a couple of the kids
Jimmy Lee the Jersey alloy yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
Jimmy lead the Jersey Outlaw takes hot
dogs Ellie this is a staple this is an
institution what
I love this we get to see him giving
notes
he wants the hype to stay up
guys keep the hype wiggling your [__]
fingers
can you guys just keep screaming the
whole time don't stop you're not paying
them Jimmy let me know the [__] you are
Jimmy League of Jersey Out Boy
[Applause]
[Music]
pinks baby I will say I do dig his
jacket I'll give him that oh he's the
outline you know yeah
[__] I can't believe there's so many
videos of him out there this is here
bumped into a huge celebrity today
another one from the subreddits
.com
[Music]
you know Jimmy goes how do you know me
as if there's any other uh
any other street that leads to Jimmy but
Mars
you're the at the end of a cul-de-sac my
friend that street is called the H3
podcast
Jimmy Lee delivers an important message
in front of dobricks is that right
speech in Hollywood
Jersey Apple
okay
[Music]
that was good
somebody's giving him good ideas out
there that that I like team Jeff they
were recorded for uh he told me 19 hours
yesterday
immigration
I tell you what man Jimmy really I wish
I could bottle that energy that that guy
has I think he never mind
you don't want that bottled
causes cancer
I was gonna say that energy is bottled
causes an end-of-life crisis
yeah it's dangerous energies to play
with
okay uh Jimmy ate someone's food again
oh I hate when he does this this is
obnoxious I hate when you do this Jimmy
it's not cool to eat people's food man
it's so closet though
ew brother that's her spoon too
oh come on what flavor oh what flavor oh
new flavor new flavor just dropped what
flavor
[Music]
Jimmy that's not funny
it's not I hate when you do that
such an [__] didn't we ask him if he
buys them a new one afterwards and he
said no yeah yeah he says no he walks
away dude this is thick that's what I
thought he did but some of y'all were
like no way he's that big of a dick he
uh gives him a free cup of fomo hey hey
come on sip on this
this is a what this is how I imagine uh
Monday being here today wait I we need
to save some of these
before we watch all these Jimmy flavors
I need I need some of these to be viewed
after he gives his sob story
on this show Dan wants to make sure that
one of these videos of him being a dick
is last to reduce the likelihood that
you guys vote for him to come I'm just
saying look I feel like a sandwich okay
here we've watched some now we should
talk to him and give us the whole sob
story everybody feel bad for him want
him on and then we'll show a few more I
think you're giving him too much credit
I think the sob story may make him look
worse okay I think so too and also we
can show I'll tell you what I'll do for
you Dan
I'll show the origins of the new flavor
sound bite
oh no
at the end well that I don't see all the
deal yeah the Los Angeles Marathon
happened and he's there creating fomo of
course
oh Jimmy
[Music]
[Applause]
get his hand he just it's always like
spread open
okay not that interesting he's been
doing it for 19 hours
I also want to point out that Jimmy is
also almost at 400 000 on Instagram holy
yeah he's gonna pass me let's go this
man's about to pass Selena Gomez he's
blowing up
um here is actually so he's got a new
catchphrase which you guys are going to
love is he ready to call in because it's
a good segue I told him to call him oh
yeah I see him in the lobby so here's
his new his old
um catchphrase was work with me or uh
work with me don't push I got problems
um this is a new one Bingo this one
combines all of them it's so here's his
new one he's working on you guys tell me
what you think
prisoners
Jimmy what's your new catchphrase
[Laughter]
so so Trevor is his limo driver who's
also a black man correct yeah and so
Jimmy thinks it's funny to just shout
Uganda so every time uh Jimmy does come
out to LA he uses Trevor's services or
his limo company or whatever
um and every time the camera's rolling
he Jimmy's like where's my wallet oh
that's so funny in front of Trevor so
uh fomo
that's really [__] up
but you said sir that's what he's saying
because it's like
how could this not be racist I mean I
hate their assumption but you mean the
Uganda or the where's my wallet the
Uganda because it I can't really even
fully make out what he's saying but I
feel like when we get him on the phone
we gotta there's Uganda I'll ask him
immediately goes afterwards that's where
Trevor was born okay so here let me know
Uganda I like how he jumps though
this is the second time he said that
girl gets uncomfortable watch she goes I
don't like that
or maybe she already said it
it's the first thing he does 21.
where do you know me from honey
see me at The Comedy Store last night
wait you reported someone wait what was
that
the reporting which is a duplicate
column
oh he just wrote I'm 20. so let's talk
to Jimmy I have lots of questions for
Jimmy now guys listen carefully because
this call is going to decide a lot
of what happens on Wednesday
so there is Jimmy Lee in Los Angeles
[Music]
hello there's my old timey type of guy
there he is where are you right now
oh I got problems I'm in a restaurant
called a petite for only three people
showed
what part of town are you in
I'm in West Hollywood West Hollywood
it's kind of funny you're probably like
only 20 minutes away from us
come down come down when you're done
we'll have something to eat okay
so how's your trip going how's your trip
going
well we we shot yesterday it was really
hard we were it was raining we had
umbrellas and uh we were really we had a
really good team and everybody hung in
and it was hard but we we got content it
was really interesting how the day went
and it was an adventure not playing to
how it went but we we got good contact
and how long did you guys shoot
yesterday
we had a really long day I'm actually
even tired today we shot I'm gonna say
the whole day was 10 hours and we shot
probably eight hours okay
that doesn't really make sense how can
you work 19 hours no not 19 hours I
probably said 10 hours
let me look back on the tags
I text you and I make mistakes when I
text we did we did shoot for 19 hours
yesterday with bad weather
it was 10. okay all right well
regardless 10 is long enough you know
let me ask you this Jimmy um
so you understand the premise of the
call today is we're going to be making a
plea to the audience watching and then
after we're done speaking we're going to
take it to a vote as if you understand
it yeah okay
so I have a couple questions I want to
ask you first
how I heard you spent twenty thousand
dollars on the trip so far
do that again
with your finger do with your finger
again no my ear plugs awesome you like
the [__] camera it's awesome it's
like a tick tock meme you know and oh
boy I got problems Ethan oh I know I
know that I got reckle up Titus Ethan my
optic nerve connects to the rectum
giving one a shitty outlook on life I
got problems so how much have you spent
on your trip so far
well we did one shoot and uh that's it
so far so we spent on one shoot
but you spent okay I heard you spent
twenty thousand I was just curious to
hear about no Zach asked me this whole
trip Hotel air and all that what am I in
for and I said probably close to 20. you
know when you add it all up that makes
sense yeah how many people are in your
entourage this time around
so yesterday we had I'm gonna say eight
eight what did they do
uh two video cameras One camera one
social media person two guards and
Trevor
and make eight people
do you think maybe that's Overkill or do
you think that's the right amount of
people for Jimmy Lee on the street
now in order to get the reactions from
the crowd they have to see a limo they
have to we have to sit in 10 minutes so
the crowd builds it's got to open before
it's coming out it has to be set up
right to get the uh right to that's all
we want you know we have it all figured
out you know it's interesting you have
basically the same amount of crew as I
do
if you imagine everybody in this podcast
Studio going out on the street that's
what Jimmy Lee's got going on
I I got a better one Ethan I was going
to invite the whole crew from H3
Thursday to a restaurant and and have my
guy film it uh I don't know if you guys
would do it but it would be phenomenal
if we could do it I think it would go
viral this Thursday I would do it if you
want
got very quiet there yeah that's
probably I mean you know it's Thursday I
don't have a babysitter and
okay I wanted to throw it out there
because I think I think I know you're
hesitant but I think if we did it it
would be good yeah let it go to be good
but well let's see you guys yeah on
Thursday I um
I forgot that I have to make dinner and
I forgot that uh Theodore's is going to
be sick on Thursday so I'm gonna have to
take care of him it's okay the dogs you
know I gotta look after the dogs I'm not
gonna have a babysitter on Thursday and
I I just don't feel like going also
that's the penultimate I I understand
yeah yeah
but thank you for the invite
you're welcome
well the last time I did went with it
sounds like she wants to go the last
time I went for a meal with Jimmy he's
sexually harassed wait Olivia
wait you want to go
volunteering
Olivia will go with you Olivia wants to
go
I saw it as a group we would have fun I
thought as a group we would have fun
yeah as a group we'd have fun anywhere
yeah my treat my treat
I told Jimmy I I'd go to dinner with him
but he has to be James weiner yeah I
can't help you Jimmy Lee No cameras I
would love to have dinner with you you
gotta be yourself I would Jack do that
off the cuff but I thought to do at 8th
Street dinner so you see guys he doesn't
want to do that Zach no no no
I would do a Shepherd dinner me and Zach
take him down a bow and just off the cup
what if we are what if we all get dinner
and there's no cameras and you're just
yourself
we could do that but it would be great
if we could do it in characters
guys don't feel too bad because I do
want to say the last time I did go out
to eat with you you did sexually harass
the waitress and I actually felt like
witnessing a crime I'm not going to do
that again yeah I learned my lesson okay
well anyway let's see how today goes so
far remember the point of this call is
to plea make a plea to the audience so
I'm not so how's it going so far do you
think
well I would I'd love to come back when
I am out here it's not like I'm out here
every week so I'd love to come on your
podcast you guys have been good to me
and you've helped me develop my my brand
and I'm very appreciative of that and I
love you guys and I hope you know that
sincerely that's that's just how I feel
I love you too I do love you too yeah
for sure
so ultimately
um
ultimately let's see what else do we
want to ask
um
let's see here
hmm
okay
[Music]
I like the music
it's old-timey hey hey Jimmy tell me
about it Jimmy tell me about your new
catchphrase Uganda
hold on oh there we go the Uganda that
was a funny skit yesterday did you watch
the part of it on the Instagram I I saw
you jumping and going Uganda
Uganda and then the lady couldn't say
right so I turned her glasses upside
down and I said say it again and she did
I said perfect so let me ask you this so
I don't understand why are you shouting
Uganda or UGA they were they were from
Uganda
if there's evidence that he was speaking
from people they weren't saying the name
of their own country right is that what
you said
Uganda it was a very funny clip
yesterday
Uganda here it is here it is but so this
is all but no see he's saying he posted
one on Instagram with all the context
wait Jimmy you did
I I I didn't do any of this yesterday I
had a girl Dave had a girl doing it but
I think I don't know if you got the
clips even up [__] is it up you have to
look on Instagram so it's not up okay
you're conf you're good I'm getting
confused I don't know if it's up I
didn't do anything so you were talking
okay I see so Uganda you screamed to the
people from Uganda exactly yeah well I
just made it like funny I made something
funny is your PR person there with you
is anyone eating with you right now
I have Danny Palmer who's one of my
social media guys super nice guy where
are you from Dan which states in Dallas
Texas Dallas Texas Dallas Dallas Texas
did he come here for this shoot he's
helping me during the week along with
two other people that are local was this
part of the fomo call you put out on the
Instagram
this was part of the ad I had out of
history
all right let me talk to him let me talk
to him to talk to Dan yeah Erie so Danny
can you hear me
Dan you want the headset here hold on
oh God
Dan
hi there Danny what's up man okay so did
you you hooked up with Jimmy because he
put out like a call looking for people
to help him
yeah he's been posting on Instagram for
a few days a few posts and um yeah I
just figured I'd emo him get some fomo
out here and see what happens man is he
paying you
um I can't really disclose that right
now
he can't even hear he can't even hear
our call yeah he won't know he's he's
treating me great we're having a good
time
um okay let me ask you this just let's
let's do this
I wasn't expecting to be on the podcast
by the way I'm a big fan but I think I
never expected to be on here well you
know you're a double agent bro I need
intel from you
of course yeah what do you want to know
okay so here without tipping off Jimmy
look at the camera keep the camera
straight and I'll say if he's paying you
blink twice
okay so he's paying you too well more
than you deserve is that what I'm
getting are you running him are you
running a scheme on him like the others
I'm trying to keep it cool right now
Ethan oh poor Jimmy
and did you come out from Texas to work
with him oh no I moved out here a few
minutes okay okay
oh yeah
wow so you're getting okay I'm gonna
pass you back to Jimmy
okay okay hold on so tell me about the
day yesterday how was it for you yeah
was it 10 or 19 hours
I was I wasn't there yesterday I was
there Saturday so he took me out to
dinner and then we kind of hung out and
got some social media that's when we ran
into uh Dr 90210 at the Nella salon so
we got some pictures there
are you embarrassed to discuss Jimmy in
front of him is that the problem
oh no not really I just I just don't
want to make him feel bad because you
know Jimmy's a little a little uh not
sensitive but he's um
he has a big heart he does yeah and a
big wall apparently too all right thank
you nice meeting you bro yeah awesome to
keep up the good work
I think he's getting I think he might be
giving a Jimmy oh this shot is
everything to me
[Music]
okay he tells us you're taking really
good care of him Jimmy
[Applause]
Dan I just met and there's another
person helping me too and they're nice
kids and they're helpful they they know
social media I don't know it yeah of
course sure is there anybody else there
is he the only one no just me and him
were just having lunch and then we were
waiting to call in at two o'clock for
you okay okay
yep so essentially
[Applause]
okay so tomorrow or on Wednesday yes I
love when you do that what are you
swiping away
uh all the Instagram people popping
images up
Instagram stuff keeps popping up
right you're getting notifications so
you're swiping them away right yeah
I do like when you do that for the
record
so don't worry just keep doing it
you know
congratulations you're almost at 400 000
uh followers on Instagram
I know we're kicking it we're cooking it
and doing phenomenal on the Instagram
yep and that's all organic right
according to my people it's all organic
[Laughter]
yeah it's all about the fomo Ethan it's
all about the fomo all right so I'm
gonna I'm gonna pass the floor to you
Jimmy
plea you can make a comment uh make a
plead to all of the audience watching
about why you should come in on
Wednesday
you're gonna say why I should come
is that what you're asking
you just set them up
it's hard to hear you because the
Coral's coming okay you want me to
explain why I should come in Wednesday
to the studio
hello oh there you're back okay so say
it again because I didn't hear it
because somebody tried to try to call
you said you wanted me to explain why I
should come in on Wednesday
now's your time Jimmy
okay so what am I doing explaining why
they come in why it should come in
go ahead
okay so I would like to I would like to
come back onto the podcast if the
audience votes me on I like coming on
you guys are nice to me you know I would
like to come back one
that's it that's all you got well I I
don't I don't know what to say you know
I'm out here and uh
somebody keeps trying to pass that's
such stupid decline okay hold on
okay
somebody keeps calling
okay I would like to come back on the
pockets if the audience would like me to
okay
I I don't know what to say it's a simple
you know it's a simple uh Ace short and
sweet
yep here
sorry I don't have a whole speech well
no it's okay you don't need a speech oh
hold on hold on working on some
and with Danny what Danny wanted me to
say which we were doing uh the first day
we met is trying to work on the legally
correct comedy a little bit kind of like
I was doing a skit like I've got
problems and I was doing like proctology
jokes and self-deprecating Jokes which
are really funny but uh they're not
let's hear one let's hear one
well I got a lot of problems with my ass
doctor his name is Dr Ben Dover the
guy's got a very shitty attitude and he
told me yesterday OS is a perfect I said
well look at you
I don't know if I agree with that but
last week he took 50 of my Colonel and
now I'm doing everything half-assed
Jimmy do you think
um that's Zach that's Zack that's Zach
stop
Jimmy have you outgrown us since your
big break on Newsmax
no I haven't outgrown you then why would
I want to come on your podcast listen I
don't know you're walking around
Hollywood you're being swarmed by fans I
don't know now look I am an old school
loyal person who just wants to get
famous and be known and you guys have
been very kind to me I'm very loyal to
you Newsmax I got lucky because the guy
that worked for them nude producer and I
did get on but I don't like
drop people I'm very loyal to people if
they or they're good to me and and
that's just how I am as a person whether
it's an employee that works for me
whether it's you guys whether it's a
social media person so that's just
pretty much how I am all right so thank
you so much and I feel the same way to
you Jimmy
in fact I think last year when
[Music]
we love you guys
stop calling
You're a Rat Bastard I don't think so
okay yeah I'm gonna block you that was a
good one right
I figured after what how to beat you
because you just you just kept going so
Jimmy
um
all right so Now's the Time Jim we we
had to push the button on something you
don't know what that is but I had to I
had to hit the button on something we
have a button that can erase but anyway
we hit the button
so uh
so
stop it all right so now
oh dude okay so now before the week
throw it to the poll I did promise Dan I
would Play a clip to kind of set it up
now we have a new sound bite of yours of
uh explaining chocolate mocha you know
colored cream yeah they're all different
flavors
explaining the origin of that sound bite
you think you could probably could you
tell us what that means what's the
context it's a setup joke you want me to
tell you the exact joke just shut up
okay so it's a cute joke so I go up to a
black girl like I'm kind of interested
and I go you know you guys come in all
flavors like a mocha chocolate coffee
dark chocolate and the girl looks at me
funny and I say what's wrong with you
I'm talking about Baskin Robbins that's
the punch
nice one yeah that's pretty much that is
pretty much the clip that I was going to
show so yeah it turns out that the clip
that we were loving so much was actually
um a little bit based in racism which I
always is the kind of the always the
Jimmy Lee lore that we love
right right
uh we lost your picture there Jimbo yeah
we just see iPhone right now
everything I know so what do I do uh did
you open a did you open a different app
did you open Instagram or something that
might have turned off the uh
oh
I don't know
I see you I see you
got Sirens
cops are coming
the coppers are coming all right should
we do this poll all right well Jimmy
we're gonna do the pull I know we can't
see you but so now
we're gonna put it to the people there's
4 500 people watching
we're asking them should Jimmy be
allowed into the studio on Wednesday
it's yes or no
yes should Jimmy Lee who is in La at the
time
basically a rock's throw from us
why can't I see me
uh should he be allowed on Wednesday
into the show we got you back Jimmy
he did it
so the so the the votes are oh my God
the votes are coming in Jimmy and you're
not botting this are you
where am I what you're not bonding the
vote on this are you now I'm sitting in
a restaurant how am I cheating I'm with
Danny well you have 400 000 uh followers
on Instagram I don't know you you you
know how to pull some strings
[Laughter]
so I gotta say to my surprise
the yeses have it at this moment
oh I'm hoping that I'm hoping I get
along that would be nice so guys if you
no gang Rise Up from peanut butter Vega
sandwich so people who do not want Jimmy
Leon you better get your voices heard
now because
Danny said I'm good right now you're
good right now people get your votes in
I thought it would be a no to be frank
well there's still time
not a lot chocolate mocha you know
colored cream yeah they're all different
flavors I thought that one would have
them the mocha joke would would uh
Collard cream yeah they're all different
flavors
people are saying bad pull should we
redo it I think there's a bad pool
because they don't like the result
be nice I'm about to storm the capital
Jimmy about these results don't do it
don't do it
oh
well I think Jimmy's got it [__] I
wasn't expecting this
uh you know there's 20 000 people
watching that haven't voted yet
dude you know how this works his ass no
no no okay Dan wants to rally the troops
to vote no Dan is saying no no I'm not
saying that I'm just saying we did I
mean there's 34 000 people watching
right now and there's ten thousand votes
yeah but Dan we know how many polls
we've done this is all this is locked up
the sample size this is locked up then
you're in denial
you're in denial bro
dad do you want to say something to Dan
he's saying he he doesn't want you
because here's exactly what I'm saying I
would like Dan to realize what I do in
my comics
and can we do have uh a guy coming in
from Cleveland to do a documentary
that's going to actually show that in
the movie I'm not really being that type
of person it's an act it's a character
I'm not really a bad guy if that's the
case if that's the case why won't you
ever interact with us out of character
that's just having a histrionic
personality
got you there Dan you got you there I'm
on board now my son says why every time
we go out can you can't just be you why
do you have to be Jimmy Lee it's not you
dance
hold on hold on hold on right let me
interject Dan I think he makes a
compelling point he says I can't even be
myself with my kids
I mean this is a philosophical question
but if if at that point is that not you
interesting is you
it's a it's a character when I had
watched it hold it
when I had lunch with you were we
talking normal what
I was talking normal we were talking an
hour ago no no behind the scenes you've
never not been joking around I've never
seen you serious
I'm not pulling away like when you came
here in person you were you were still
on the entire time yeah when I when I
come with you guys I am more character
like if I do I was gonna
we were talking the limo with the videos
let me interject here a little bit the
pull is moving I want to say it the nose
are uh-oh they're creeping up a little I
want to say
and you can blame Dan for that Jimmy but
you're still in the lead
by myself but what I want to say is Dan
makes an interesting point Jimmy he says
[Music]
if when you go out you are this Jimmy
Lee character who's super offensive and
mean and racist and uh misogynistic and
fat phobic and yeah
hold on let me finish my boy so if
you're all those things as Jimmy Lee
every time you go out
done at what point are you you are just
Jimmy Lee that's just who you are right
that's your real authentic self when
you're out
no no I'm I'm not in character all the
time you're wrong when you go any
character a lot but not all the time
okay okay well we've just never seen
no no no
so Zach I I call you out on a date for
dinner where I will be James Weiner and
then Zach can witness it just me and him
one-on-one
hold on
okay one at a time one at a time one at
a time to Jimmy's credit when we do talk
there are times where he is James weiner
I will give him that no he said wiener
wiener Winer whatever
um it's weiner right
whatever you want it to be no what is it
I wouldn't order a whiner weiner yeah it
is weiner okay that's cut that must have
been tough through life huh that's
another chapter we'll go through another
time yeah I've had I've had many hearts
of hearts with Jimmy I will give him
that okay okay when he's James weiner
this Jimmy Lee character I don't want to
go to dinner with I love you but I can't
go to dinner with it I think Dan and
Jimmy need to go to dinner together oh
my God I would film that now there's a
bit I would could film just a one-on-one
huh but I don't want to go with you guys
you guys what you guys want to do if we
all go out for dinner
no you want her weiner you want to go to
dinner with the normal doctor for
Christ's sake you have a doctorate
you're a literal PhD of [__] MD or
whatever the [__] you're a doctor man
CMD DMD DMD anti-dentite
yeah
so we'll all go out for dinner and I'll
be my normal self no Jimmy Lee
then you'll see how it really yeah
[__] I I don't believe you okay
wait this is an interesting bit
developing Jimmy takes us all out to eat
the challenge is for him to be weiner
the whole time right
can he be weiner the whole time
there it is that's a good that's a
that's very good good point you like
that segment idea
I like that idea yeah
how's the Dentistry going
business could be better oh I'm sorry to
hear that
it's covered related with Staffing and
revenue it's not everybody's having it
it's not just me so what am I going to
do is it possible that your focus is
more on your comedy career than your
Dentistry no
your dentist I'm losing Dennis's or
orderly time you can't it's hard to
replace them and the revenue you're
lowering from just reimbursements with
insurance companies but it's not just me
it's all Dennis is
almost impossible how much do you pay a
dentist if you hire them but dentists
can make over 200 a year two hundred
thousand
yep I figured they'd make a lot more
than that
well my good ones make more but most of
them make about two two and a quarter
and that's what you you pay them that
salary
yep
there you go
that's funny in La I feel like every
doctor's a millionaire because they all
have like their own well no no out here
the rates are higher for you know
expenses and Staffing and doctors
because it's more the metric cost of
living out here is higher
you know they may make more how about
what what about this as a compromise
Jimmy we'll send you to dinner with
Bizarro Zach and Ethan
you you and Ethan Bizarro Zach and Ethan
who's that it's fake there's a fake
look-alike Zach and a fake look-alike
Ethan would you eat dinner with them no
I want to go with you guys wait wait
what do you mean you mean with fake
Ethan
yeah me and fake Ethan yeah no I want to
go with you your whole crew and be James
weiner
that's the best I can do
no that's no I want to go with you guys
I know you guys I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding
well if if you have someone that you
look that looks like you that you could
send that'd be then then that's what
if Danny I can give Danny a Jimmy Lee
Mass okay
so Danny Bizarro Zack and fake Ethan
will all have a meal together
way out and I'm going to prove that Dan
I can be James weiner
all right well so well the well that
sounds like it's a plan because the
yeses have it I mean Dan are you ready
to call this
yeah I mean it's 10 10 points up he's
got you got a 10 point lead there Jimmy
the people love you what can I say
I appreciate the love and I appreciate
you guys
it's pretty close it's pretty close you
know it's a five percent spread but
there it is so on Wednesday we're gonna
have to
um
we're gonna have to have you in here and
figure it out so so so congratulations
thank you honey on your big break do you
want them to do another stand-up routine
Ethan I'm gonna have to think about what
I want I don't know if I can endure
another stand-up and Frank why don't I
come in it's just James weiner because
last year when I came in that one time
and we were talking about seriously how
I grew up and all that there was a lot
of love with fans and I think I'd like
to come in that way
just as Jim weiner on Wednesday we
should have a serious conversation maybe
no no it's like just what is myself what
if I bring a therapist now Dr Fidel and
you can just tell them everything
no I just think we should
be friends talk and I'll be just me not
Jimmy that's all yeah
if that's okay with what you guys want
it's your show
right sometimes I forget that when I'm
talking to you all right Jimmy thank you
so much we'll we'll see you on Wednesday
congratulations man you want you did it
like what time am I coming so I can play
in my day
Joanna says I feel like we're in a toxic
relationship we can't break free from so
cool
don't say that you guys are my buddies
no yeah okay Jimmy listen I'll talk
we'll talk we'll be in touch about
Wednesday okay
okay what around 1 30. I'll call you
Jimmy
later today okay okay I really
appreciate you guys having me back we'll
see you then all right God bless you bye
honey all right bye honey with the honey
that's a new thing since when you
calling me honey
you're my honey bunny okay honey bunny
he's hangs up when we hang up the phone
he always says it to me all right honey
bye honey all right sweetheart thank you
bye pumpkin bye pumpkin
bye bunny rabbit bye honey bye sugar
plum love you love you sweetie love you
baby love you poopy love you teddy bear
all right puppy love you teddy fresh
all right Jimbo
all right Ethan about see you buddy
all right love bug
okay love all right bug see you later
love you love you all right love you bud
I guess
I guess let's leave it open I'm kind of
curious what's happening and this is
interesting
let's just leave this open
can you hear anything is there there's
background hi honey
lipstick to us hey sweetheart
all right we're gonna set we're gonna
we're gonna say goodbye all right
I love I love
that wait what was that love screaming I
mean I've been trying to make him click
the screen and [__] because he can see
me on soon it's so funny I could see
that yeah
was he clicking it I don't know
my fave is when he was swiping it was so
funny
guys y'all are gonna get mad at me but
you all voted for this [__]
I thought for sure you guys would vote
no because there's just people the
haters you know only like half the
audience probably like half of our
viewers half of the audience is gonna
okay so I'm trying we have to think of
something that would be fun and fresh
uh to include Jimmy
um I'm not sure what that is we didn't
get this part because we didn't think he
would uh win maybe we can have him do a
challenge like uh that spicy chip
challenge
gonna kill the poor bastard put him out
of his misery though
ask him if he is good with spicy food or
something like that just like totally
nothing comedy related
you know
ask him he's good with spicy
I'll do it with them okay
the last time I did it was one of the
worst things that ever happened to me
but I'll do it again
okay Jimmy Lee everybody
to my surprise man
you all want more Jimmy Lee
which is kind of surprisingly cream yeah
they're all different did that surprise
you Dan
it didn't surprise me necessarily but I
vote I I don't even want to disclose
this but
I did vote a certain way that I wasn't
planning on but like sitting confronted
with the option I voted as in a certain
way
that surprised me
[Music]
I'll let you determine it's yeah it's a
tough situation because he came in here
he was really nice but like you know he
met Lena he's like oh where are you from
she's like oh I'm Lebanese he's like
don't shoot
well as I say he was very lovely
that it that's the histrionic he he is
genuinely such a nice guy yeah but he
can't it's it's a really interesting uh
character study he's such a sweet guy
who can't help but like [__]
brutalize you with the most offensive
[__] ever oh show them the prolapse
that's a really good idea is there a way
we can make him regret coming nah okay
yeah you can have him come in on
Thursday so like he won't ever want to
come back have him come in and talk to
Hassan
I'm thinking show them the prolapse
have them do the spicy chip right what
other misery whatever they put on them
maybe Sam can make some drinks
concoction or something like a fish
smell that ever again no think of it
Sam do you have do we have more of that
I don't know if we have it but I can try
to get it in time you think you can get
that by Wednesday
uh I work in mysterious ways
they're all different flavors so so if
Jimmy can
eat the chip and taste the feak of fish
then I feel like
he kind of deserves some respect yeah
absolutely if you can overcome that if
he could survive that I think we might
[__] kill yeah no he's gonna drop
should we have a paramedics the the chip
you know if he doesn't want to do that
we won't force him to do that but the
the fish in the prolapse he can handle
that
I mean he's a doctor he's seen gross
stuff you know
that's true
she might not be phased
that sounds fun now I'm excited for
Wednesday actually let's see what sticks
man you never know with him
all right so there that is
hey you guys the winner of our green
screen competition who made
the Beloved
uh smash single that's taken the World
by storm Fly Me to the Moon
oh yeah
[Applause]
this guy is the man beast from space
he has put out a new song in
collaboration with our very own Zach
Bernstein
[Applause]
he sent you the uh music and asked you
to rip a solo over it Zack he sent me
the track I loved it similar vibe to
this and he's like do your thing and I'm
like you got it and I sent him back same
day I think it was a few hours later and
um I love the tune
um love what he did with it Aaron's very
talented
um I'm excited for everyone to hear it
hey you shredded on it man
this guy beast from space is a real
up-and-coming talent
you know
I think the three of you might have a
really interesting thing like we might I
could see you guys really going on tour
yeah super group yeah Eric Clapton was
in a super group we're cream and Eric
Clapton is basically a cover of the next
one is Tears in Heaven yes
a very moving and tragic song extremely
written about uh Clapton's son who
passed away uh but a nook's voice is uh
that song is so [__] oh yeah it's
hard to even think about yeah yeah
so here they go uh Tears in Heaven would
you know my name if you saw me in heaven
though Zach and a Nook features here it
is
[Music]
every voice
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
universe
[Music]
you all ready
is it coming Zach or it's coming true
[Applause]
[Music]
God's tears
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hell yeah
a Nook is becoming a bona fide celebrity
over here seriously he's in space yeah
uh true talent I just want to give a big
shout out to Aaron great dude great
person Aaron from bees from space bees
and yeah bees from space uh a Nook and
Zach Lewis
wow
dude you're such a [__] Zach is a
master marketer man
I didn't put that Zach Lewis
May 13th but I did not put them you get
it out there though you you get in
people's minds yeah yeah so live with
the Roxy by the way speaking of um live
shows
do we have any details about our next
one Dan not yet
that is there is workings it is
that's fun
it's in the weeks do we know how many
seats approximately we're looking at
uh between like 1100 and 1500 something
like that oh okay that's great last one
was uh 700 okay perfect 800. so quite a
bit bigger perfect that's awesome we're
getting
uh we're get we're getting pricing from
a number of venues but they're all in
that range fantastic that's exciting and
also um
Zach is going to be tearing up the Roxy
a Nook will be joining you I heard uh
sure yeah totally flying in for Middle
he's flying in from Italy for the Roxy
show
so did we ever read the message that
Nook sent us we did yeah yeah
hey this is interesting Bing AI someone
who has access to it
says
uh this was submitted
I hear Ryan Cavanaugh looks like Harvey
Weinstein is there a website that can
help me tell the difference hello this
is Bing I can help you with that right
kayvena
and Harvey weissen are both former movie
producers that face legal troubles and
controversies they've also been friends
and business partners in the past
however they do not look very much alike
who the [__] hold up this is the wrong
one who the [__] are they to make like
you're a robot you can't even see idiot
it's giving away it's linking to our
website as uh you can see some pictures
of them on this website
that's oh now it says number one maybe
they're interpreting because our website
is no they are different people right
right
click the link again in the in the dock
so it's doing its job it says Ryan
cabinet has red hair and blue eyes
Harvey has dark brown hair nice you can
see some of the pictures on this website
okay well hold on let me see
there's another one
where they have a full a more in-depth
conversation with being AI
they says oh my God tell me about Ryan
Kavanaugh
if you just scroll down to the last part
uh here they says does Ryan Kevin look
like Harvey Weinstein yes
there is a website called this which
compares the faces
ostensibly so people can tell the two
apart the website was created by
YouTuber Ethan Clyde and has been the
subject of cyber Squad in case filed by
Kavanaugh that's crazy wow I knew about
that dude that's awesome pretty cool
these AIS are so freaking cool dude yeah
I I paid for the chat gpt4
and I've been using it at home and it's
like if I this thing is an amazing
writer
and they ha it has the knowledge of
everything if I was in college with this
thing I would be unstoppable bro I would
never have to go to class yeah be
careful though because I I personally
have had it spit out
completely factually untrue things a
couple times well read it right and well
and and follow up even on any
assertations that it makes uh because it
it see it it says it in such a confident
way that you're like wow this is amazing
and then you look it up and it's like
wait that's completely the opposite you
know it's true
most of the time it's good I'm just
saying it it makes mistakes I majored in
English literature and CR and creative
writing if I had this [__] thing then
I wouldn't have to go to class once I
would get straight A's with this [__] I
think that there are uh
there are sort of competing uh language
models that are all about detecting if
it was written by an AI or not oh uh as
well so yeah but you but that's just
conjecture you'll be like no this wasn't
written by AI like what you know it's
like no I wrote it can be detective
though pretty easily
with other AIS that detect that right
that is my understanding really well
yeah I'm sorry Dave because the thing is
you can you can even be like right
rewrite this but less like an AI you
could you could do that you could really
like this rewrite this but dumb it down
a little bit right and it does that and
it's still like pretty good
it's yeah there's no doubt that it is
and then you go rewrite it but dumb it
down more
because you don't want to turn in like a
perfect paper you dumb it down a few
levels
so then be like check what I sent to you
so here's from uh
in the midst of rank Kavanaugh drama
this is from chat GPT yeah when um
there's a plot there's a plug-in for
shot gpt4 that
sites stuff from Google so it actually
has access to Google with the help of
Google Chrome oh in the midst of the
Ryan Cavanaugh drama a meme emerged
suggesting that he looks somewhat like
Harvey wants in the resemblance led to
public confusion prompting Ethan love to
create wow I don't even know about love
this site was meant to address this
issue and help the public differentiate
between the two individuals The public's
reaction website was positive
and one user even saying finally we can
breathe again
to be honest I think being
done did a little more intelligent
uh well it uses the same uh technology
it's just it gives slightly different
answers what about being his chat gbt
yeah oh idiot
stupid well
idiot not you no I'm saying you're not
an idiot for just not knowing that it
just it that that is the uh no I was
calling the bot the Bing bot in it okay
gotcha
anyways
so let's see uh main stories
um big Nick update oh god I've been
wanting to do this
making fun of big Nick has become my
favorite thing in the world because he's
such a [__] Goblin like just a
hateful Goblin
who found Jesus
and it's turned him into a hateful
little troll and again I don't say that
I don't say that in reference to a
stature I will call anyone a hateful
little troll you know
like
keemstars hey fellow troll although he
is quite short as well
so maybe a good example would be
Logan Paul's a hateful little troll he's
tall taller
was I clear
enough
play the play the video and all be
forgiven all right so yeah here's Big
Nick he made a tweet about women's
attire in the gym you cannot handle it
you guys
Big Nick
he says it's so disgusting
when I see women dressed like
prostitutes in the gym yo bro you better
chill your [__] Jets right now
prostitutes are you [__]
you don't have to wear Spandex and yoga
pads there's plenty of other clothing I
shouldn't have to feel like I'm in a
strip club when I'm just trying to work
on my health it's annoying that's
definitely a you problem bro
this dude is straight up ready to start
the caliphate who wants to make
isis-friendly gyms
I know what big Nick needs he needs a
men's only gym to protect
he needs a men's only world I feel like
he'd be most comfortable man's only
world yeah yeah in his perfect world he
would just put his dick in a hole if he
wanted a kid come back in nine months
he go to the Jordan Peterson Chinese
dick suck in fact
that's right when a girl has leggings on
and and work out a tire that's it's too
[__] it's like she's having sex it's
like it's like she's having sex with me
from across the room literally and I
hate that a prostitute it's gross girls
are so icky I hate it a prostitute
you're so harlot it's like I feel like
formal sorry I'm wearing my cute set
from gym shark or whatever like Coco
Lulu's the Devil he's ready to go to war
with Lululemon
nah he's not alone all right big Nick
then I need you if that's the world you
want to live in that I need you to dress
in
loose clothes long sleeve shirts long
sleeve pants I don't need your sexy
[__] thighs
I don't see your abs if I see your
calves I'm going to cover up cover up
cover up four
it's like
it's just you it's a you problem like do
you see how pathetic you are
holy [__] how's this guy ever gonna find
a significant other like oh my God
he's just he's trying to go so
conservative that he gets like an
arranged marriage that's the only way
this guy's gonna ever touch a woman
he used it to plug his song If you go to
his response tweet no yeah you wrote a
song about the gym
I think he's just in general they hate
me
let's hear it is this Gonna Get Us
claimed can you see uh it probably will
by who
he's got to be publishing this
independently didn't he have a tweet
about like certain frequencies with
music like uh certain type was the
devil's frequency oh is he one of those
guys yeah he's a 434 uh dude yeah yeah
whatever it is yeah do you know about
all that Ethan we talked about it like
have we yeah he I think he even made a
video about it
um there's certain frequencies that oh
yeah we've talked about this demon
frequency yeah yeah
Anita said
I wonder why I've literally never seen
bi lesbian women getting pressed about
this aren't Men supposed to be less
sensitive and fragile
Nick actually took the opportunity to
promote he said
actually address this in my new song
my response sad
you know why your music career will
never take off because you're talentless
right
God ain't good we haven't heard it yet
don't say that God is not going to give
you uh good talent because you [__]
hate women what if they hate me is just
straight fire we don't know well I'm
willing to hear it I actually ripped the
solo on this song
hate to break into you
this um cross is a little small just
saying it could be bigger
a little subtle true God is like bro
come on step up your cross again is it
just like it's just the crucifix with no
no dying Jesus on it oh oh Dan's about
to drop some knowledge no no not I'm
just saying he could be a lot more
devout I mean I want to see his
mutilated body up there I agree the
wound on the side from the Lance and
everything like yes I want to see it all
I agree you're being kind of being it's
disrespectful to his salary you're
half-sending Jesus Loser yeah
oh he responded he says it's absolutely
hilarious how triggered people got over
this bro first of all let's not talk
about trigger you're the one triggered
in the gym
you are the one by some yoga pants
you don't get to be like oh you guys get
so mad
you know you don't get to flip the
script you're the triggered little
[__] baby [__] that can't even go to
a public space without having a busy fit
and [__] your [__] gym shorts in
the words of Zach a meltdown like so you
can't be like
yo y'all getting triggered it's like no
dude you are and we're making fun of you
it says this is your weights Eyes On The
Ground then you can go back home right
yeah just exercise at home if the world
is that is that hard for you to deal
with yeah
this is proof we live in a pathetic
generation he says I address the
controversies here in my new song
the work I'm such a dork
I'll tell you what man these gates are
not swinging open for you brother
you know Zach you need to tweet some
wild [__] like that and then just
respond to everyone Zach Lewis live I'm
in the Rock that's a good idea maybe
that's not bad
uh we're seeing if it gets claimed and
then we'll listen to it big Nook it
sounds like you want us to so check it
out very excited
oh this is an interesting uh
self-portrait uh big Nick posted
I just saw it in his photos
I think he looks good here
what is going on in this image it's
Monsters Inc he's like [__] in a
sink no no it's when he gets sucked by
that uh that machine you know it sucked
off my machine pretty much like the
Randall yeah
um no immediate claim though
all right really
yo I'm so excited to bring you big next
new song
all right so this is the
this is his response they hate me okay
let's hear it
can't listen to it I have a YouTube give
me the YouTube yeah
I think I'm the only person in the world
that doesn't have Spotify I use
YouTube music and let me say
people go oh why do you use YouTube
music I support my own ecosystem okay
it's a good app and you get it for free
with a [__] YouTuber premium
subscription so it's awesome guess what
close the economy and once again I don't
know why YouTube doesn't know how to
[__] sell that it's a great deal and
they should [__] pay me to promote it
her
interesting benefits everybody
absolutely Joe Brendan and it get hot I
got a lot of I got Harry
did you send me the YouTube link what's
up yeah I did that's a big game man
send in the wrong chat oh I'm in the
wrong chat
my bad yeah yeah yeah you're okay Dan
thank you all right here it is they hate
me official
so oh God the like ratio is off here man
not good
God [__] god did not favor this video
4 000 views after
uh seven day or yeah 13 days actually
yikes
all right big Nick should let's hear
your response
yeah you're going to hell for that
whoa
you're going to hell for that one
brother
thank you
[Music]
leg forward
Jesus
he gave us authorities
[Music]
that's just the soundtrack what the [__]
gameplay
sacrifices
[Music]
I was just a response to you being a pig
it was click baiting he knows the game
you think that's the time let me ask you
a serious question big net
you really think God wants to listen to
that [__]
of all the people he's created all the
world's history he is our creator one
and only right he's created Mozart
he's created The Beatles Leonard all
these [__] insanely talented people
who are not singing about God they're
singing about their objective experience
in this world which again that's why God
put us here right to experience life
we you don't need to Sing About God bro
he doesn't care
you know he's not putting that on I
guarantee God don't want to listen to
that [__] don't waste his time like that
with something like this
God wants to listen to like simple man
yeah or like Zeppelin you know just have
like some some rock star with like angel
wings you know right yeah not some
[__] 808 trash [__] you know yeah I'm
just saying bro of all the music
probably they're probably back like when
we were coming out of the caves and [__]
there's probably some fire ass ooga
booga beats too just like
hitting some tiger skin with a bone oh
yeah it's a mad basement Rivals like
some poly Rhythm [__] yeah 12-8 [__]
yeah just [__] entire music it's like
that you know nobody oh [__] stop it I
forgot about this image
[Laughter]
Jesus literally yeah
just stop it's powerful just make good
music yeah I mean like you don't have to
lean on Jesus
she's like hey don't don't [__] put
take me into this dude
yeah so there it is uh Big Nick
is out there
with this hot takes
here he retweeted this I wish they would
segregate gyms based on sex nobody wants
to work out with these paranoid [__]
okay you [__] up bro
you genuinely are pig like [__] you
[__] shut up shut the [__] up freak
ugh so gross
here's what he thinks about the Jews
I think he likes him better than the
Muslims really you think yeah he says we
worship like a moon god of fire or some
[__] whoa yeah but you know he thinks
the juice spirit is boy
oh yeah without a doubt that's not good
well we look like prostitutes and gyms
he hates women the most yeah that's for
sure I think we win today
and if there's one thing that is famous
about Jesus is that he wanted nothing to
do with uh prostitutes right Mary
Magdalene yeah yeah yeah no he hated her
that was that's the main takeaway that's
funny because Jesus loves [__]
yo this Doc is uh I need access
can I can I tell a pet peeve to you guys
hmm
it drives me crazy when I get a doc that
I don't have access to and it happens
all the time
and this isn't pointed at you guys it's
point it happens to me all across my my
professional life and world people they
sending documents and they don't share
access it's like it's like come on it's
come on man 23 give um so when the
request access button nobody [__]
here's the thing we have a work group
that everybody is supposed to
automatically be uh shared on but if
somebody accidentally uploads to like
their personal Gmail account which is
what I'm assuming happened right here
then this one is on the H3 podcast
Channel
is it really mm-hmm
try it now yeah I got you know it works
it's just I don't know oh I see what
you're saying it's just you know it's
one of those things but whatever
I love
the it's just
no I hate seeing that screen too I know
what you mean because I think you hit
request access it does it takes forever
they don't see it they don't see that
you gotta reach out to them and you got
to make sure
that you're like hey I don't have access
you know you got a whole conversation
about it
then you they go oh try now they go oh
no try now you got to refresh it it's
like oh it's still not working
yeah exactly yeah no I got it it is
annoying so this man has an account
called
[Music]
um
is that you that was definitely Larry
David yeah definitely but what the [__]
was that was that intentional it was a
little curb moment you were having her
okay but so fast
it's amazing it's recognizable from just
one note yeah
thank you for the gifted from Queen
smugginess
all right here's another uh big Nick is
be uh spitting all over the Bible says
in First Corinthians 6 19 for you are in
the gym right now
yeah that's why he's praying you are in
this he's in an Unholy place
stop going if it's that Unholy just work
out at home weirdo
could probably find a like Christian uh
the Bible says youth group to work out
with them
in 619 that our body is a temple of the
Holy Spirit I see way too many fat
Creations nowadays and it's mind-blowing
like if we really believe in the word of
God we're going to act like it right and
we want to take care of our body because
we want to bring honor to God the world
wants to make you fat lazy and docile
right but we got to rebel against the
world because we're not of the world
we're of the kingdom of heaven so let's
start acting like we believe in God's
word let's take care of our bodies let's
take care of our health because gluttony
is a sin at the end of the day and we
want to show glory to God not just in
what we speak but what we do so get in
the gym get on a diet and if this
convicts you I'm happy
God hates fat people there you heard it
I always knew that I always had a
feeling
you know always had a feeling that was
right
God be or Nick be out here like women
are [__] and God hates fat people any
other how it takes
yeah Jesus Jesus knows a proper attire
at the gym uh you know listen
fully CL dressed big neck is taken out
to the back
can you cover those arms please Nick
you're kind of a [__]
little [__] Jesus gets an exception
because he is Son of God after all but I
could almost see his [__] happy trail
chromosis pubes
his dick is just right there dude
that's kind of dope
Jesus has a hog
absolutely
no debating that I mean obviously right
right
the Lord
the [__] of Jesus
is a perfect seven inches
y'all know that the [__] of Jesus is a
perfect
seven inches amen
and a girth of
he's got a perfect nice and girth theme
12 inch but I give it a light six it's
got a nice meaty girth to it as well
amen
and when Jesus comes with his Rod of
perfect proportions and size earthy you
will know
his name is the Lord girthy
girthy like girthy as salvation itself
Lord
he has a massive penis
all right thank you amen
so there's big Nick love that thank you
big Nick
that's some fun videos you guys want to
watch
[Applause]
you scared this [__] is [__] wild man
uh
the title is I think he lied on his
resume
did this man it's so funny he's good yes
take me down please chill
take the chill pill
Trail
why are you scared take me down
look you ain't that hot you ain't that
high
down from here
this guy's a demon kind of for that but
like I guess this guy's also an idiot if
you've was like yeah I can do that I can
go [__] 20 stories up in a
scaffolding
funny [__]
thank you to um good old jazzle five
subbies and talking beanie 20 subbies
talking to you baby
mm-hmm beautiful
um 4chan user accused of threatening to
kill Sheriff gets arrested at Mom's
house
where else would he live
this is fun
let's take a look at the 4chan user
I'm sure he's gonna be a total Chad as I
can say he's probably jacked Yeah clean
cut sparkling eyes life is together
clean room yep
I know it
what is this life and crime Network
it's a YouTube channel well it might be
more than that but another I remember uh
the channel that all of the deaf herd
trial was happening yeah wow good for
them they got a whole weird interesting
thing going on
we're looking for a real handsome clean
cut yeah
about six foot
even the mom is so stereotypical like
old lady she doesn't know what's going
on sweet clueless okay sweetie sure
whatever you need
hey Grandma can you buy me some
ammunition I'm looking for some 20 23 I
don't know anything about it I'm looking
for some uh 23 hollow point
armor piercing rounds okay sweetheart
sure absolutely
thank you Emma Cypress for the 20. thank
you guys so much
uh probably the police I do find it
interesting that she just let him in
though she's like I don't know who you
are but come on in come on in they're
here here it's happening it's happening
you step down here please what's up here
he comes down here
show me that guy oh wait what he's in
the attic at least not the basement
let me take a look at him
come here
he was threatening
to kill a sheriff that's probably not a
good idea yeah generally holy [__] bro
just so you know where there's a uh
a warrant out of Volusia County Florida
he's a grandma Grandma I need you to do
one thing please erase my browser
history
grandma please microwave my hard drive
all right
the internet that you're aware of what's
going on yeah I was I was uh I think I
saw you there what you talked about yeah
yeah right okay okay
we'll do everything
um
search version for uh electronic devices
um what's upstairs oh no they got a
search warrant for his devices I don't
know anything about this man but I know
whatever's on that computer is gonna
[__] his life up holding Milk porn so uh
I just sent you the uh the scoop a New
Jersey man was arrested Monday at his
mother's home after authorities said
they traced online death threats made
against a Florida Sheriff back to the 38
year old 30 said Rick is a hard 38. this
man is like the same age as you
he's a year older than me right
okay so I'm 37 you admit it okay Ethan
caught you hit the button hit the button
bought you
thank you Dan we'll talk about this
later [__]
my 40th birthday I was in Las Vegas
busted
[Music]
uh so he says Authority said Richard
golden allegedly threatened to end
but Lisa Sheriff Mike chitwood's life
after the law enforcement leader took a
stand against a Neo-Nazi hate group oh
so he's a Nazi too
bro look at yourself there's no master
race
if you're the master race we don't want
you
like come on bro
they all look like this too this is not
the master race
love
[Laughter]
the anonymous chat said to be posted by
Golden called for shooting [__] but in
the head to solve an immediate problem
permanently
Sheriff Chitwood said he can't wait to
welcome golden when he gets off the
plane and arrives at jail holy [__]
oh
that is not good my friend yeah
especially they search that hard drive
only God only knows what kind of Lolly
[__] is on there
[Music]
anime where they look younger yeah that
shit's [__] up it's crazy
that guy's got a whole Lolly collection
for sure
um
he is 38 though that is like really sad
so I understand where the you know anger
comes from it's sad we need to reach out
to these men because Jordan Peterson
can't be the only answer
like how do we accept people like that
well a guy like this ever like me
if I don't tell I the thing it's like I
don't know if they're ready to hear
anything but every problem of yours is
the world's fault
or it's this group's fault um
to women's fault it's liberals fault
like how can I get through to these
people so they don't want [__] how do
I reach these kids
you know because I get it he's angry
he's 38 he lives in the Attic gonna stop
dissing the Nazis all the time that's
not the answer that is not the answer
you don't believe in Jesus Christ you
are wrong
that's okay all right big Nick and Kanye
should link up
but do you know what I'm saying I just
don't know how because they all these
kinds of people they only fall down
these rabbit holes of hate
and they closed the world on themselves
and
they some reason turn into Nazis like
nine out of ten times
what's that that was my campaign was was
Hitler just like a giant virgin loser he
looked like this
he was a
yeah he was kind of a loser he was a big
time loser micro penis well Hitler had
he was at least
um one testicle too right he had a micro
yeah isn't that I don't know if that
I've never heard that thing that would
explain a lot yeah did Hitler
[Music]
did Hitler really have a micropenis
um
he Hitler himself is believed to have
two forms of genital abnormalities an
undescended testicle which is a rare
condition called penile hypso patius
in which the urethra opens on the
underside of the penis no [__] shot
the urethras on the bottom of his dick
what what that's what it says
what is the condition called it's called
penile
hippospadius
it says the urethra opens on the
underside of the penis
I don't know if I want to see a picture
of this but um confused oh you gotta
yeah tell me boys with hypnosadius the
urethra forms abnormally during weeks 8
to 14 of pregnancy
a normal app opening can form anywhere
from just below the end of the penis to
the scrotum dude
[Music]
oh my God yo Hitler pissed out of his
nuts this is some wild [__] he is
starting he literally had pea stored in
the balls
man it's a more efficient way to pee it
let's touch this area to travel
a telegraph cited the news this week and
the internet went crazy online headlight
jumped to weird conclusions like Hitler
had a micropenis so he didn't have a
micro penis he just pissed from his
balls yeah no wonder he was [__] mad
dude or ball because he also had only
one because of the other thing right
yeah
wow did you get a picture of that I
didn't click on images
I saw a lot of surgery picks okay
nowadays I imagine that's totally uh uh
addressable I mean I don't know that for
sure but plug the hole up dude just plug
it up
yeah
imagine pissing from your nuts holy [__]
oh piss balls
I do wonder if he and like back then he
was fighting Wars they were probably
just pissing anywhere like you know
people saw him pissing from his mouth
interesting and they probably made fun
of him if he if he peed normally I do
wonder if there would have not been a
holocaust
that it's one of the great questions of
History wait so so he peed like that
does that mean when he ejaculated it
also came out of no it's just no it's
one hole no it's the same well it's one
whole brother he comes out of his nuts
doesn't that eliminate him from
um Master race I feel like that's a d
That's like a defect oh that's a deep
defect well that's the whole point is he
didn't want people to be like him the
self-hatred yeah yeah I mean
unironically I'm sure there's a lot of
self-hatred going on there of somebody
that winds up like that yes yes for sure
okay well anyway back to this guy
empty Mountain Dew bottles
so there that is so um you know shout
out
shout out
the master race as always you know I
like to rep the master race whenever I
can
I love the master race
man arrested for blowing up 7-Eleven
bathroom
did you see this this went like Mega
viral in the last couple days here it is
I did see yeah I've seen that
yeah so he's had a seven of them and
taking a dump
now I want to say
I'm still skeptical about this video
yeah there's no place there's nothing
every article on it there's all I see is
like social media news talking about it
I haven't seen any but it like it seems
so real
I think it is fake because look the oh
he's inside the bathroom yeah no in a
second and that's it
I pooped my pants
someone said this is you before every
show
that's me at the door yeah we're all at
the door you gotta stand up right now no
wiping
come on man oh that's real those are
please bruh that's I mean no those
that's real [__] so here's the thing
though this video was just randomly
uploaded in like several parts to tick
tock and he didn't explain anything and
the account doesn't have any other posts
it's real come on I lead towards real
but I I'm I'm hedging a little bit
because it's just so bizarre okay here
this is all I'll find any info on it his
whole account is just yeah why is he
he's reposting the same video eh I'm
just gonna say I think it's broken up
into chunks the original is not censored
just so you know so well he's right you
see his turds at one point so he shows
this [__] yeah and when he's finally
leaving he turns around and you see the
toilet well it wasn't lying this one
says Story Time coming soon but it was
two days ago and there hasn't been any
well if he showed his turds he got to be
a real dude you got to be real I I mean
yeah people keep saying uh because he's
uh people think um the police having a
paintball gun or something that appears
to be a paintball gun that means it's
not real I'm pretty sure that's a uh
what do you call it non-lethal yeah yeah
they're not showing up it's a non-lethal
round yeah which is actually nice I'm
glad to see that they're not ready to
kill the man as he's taking [__] at
least although they do think he's armed
if they're maybe they're just protecting
themselves from [__] spray
like bro you really [__] swarmed this
man on the toilet I told you I needed
you to come out and chat with me I think
this one's so viral because a lot of
people are saying this is their worst
fear okay
this is your worst fear for me we don't
get to wipe finish wipe yeah I'm just
too shy I don't want anyone yeah 10
people opening the door and staring at
you while you're on the toilet
I love this guy looking at him through
the blast Shield you can see his face
yeah he calls it pepper ball gun right
there there you go
you guys are so slain like bro you got a
look at how he's like cowering behind
the shield like you're so lame it's a
man he's on the toilet like there's not
a more vulnerable position he could be
in right he is not gonna shoot you or do
anything
[Music]
oh just to keep the door open yeah
they're incompetent dude look at them
why are they so scared
most dangerous job in the world I don't
know this is I mean what is he wanted
for like maybe he's one it doesn't say
anything about it we have no in we have
no Intel did he I forgive me if I'm
wrong but I might have heard a few
seconds ago if I'm hearing he said
because of a warrant he did say that
yeah he did say that okay yeah but I
mean Ward's couldn't vary in severity
quite a bit right
I'm scared I feel endangered and I feel
scared and I y'all want to shoot this
thing well hey at least if he's scared
and he needs he [__] his pants he's in
the right place you know like this is
perfect
I'd like to wipe my ass so I don't smell
like ass please
dude I'm not [__] scared
I don't have the gun I don't have
anything I literally just trying to take
a [__] oh
he said I don't have the gun he said I
don't have a gun I'm sure I thought he
said Doug gone I think he's really a gun
I don't have the gun I don't have
anything oh he did say it did he say so
he does have a gun somewhere he said the
gun
I'd like to wipe my ass so I don't smell
like ass please
can I wipe my
ass I don't have the gun I don't have
anything I literally just I don't have
the gun
hmm
trying to take a [__] I don't wipe my
ass bro
[Music]
can I please wipe my ass
you know just let him wipe his ass right
I mean
it would be faster probably just what if
he's hiding a gun in the toilet bowl
you're right you got a point man these
police they're trained never you know
he's right isn't that a scene in
Godfather yeah
you're absolutely right though Dan
that's what they're thinking but also
like I feel like it'd be a lot more
pleasant for the police officers in the
squad car if they let him wipe his ass
you know someone says he could have
thrown [__] at them
and they got the shield it's fine the
[__] Shield
I want people to walk out with us I have
a discussion with us I'm 29 years old
trying to rebuild my life and I feel
bullied
active and accurate
and you are who's talking there you are
go ahead hey Miriam I know the [__] you
think you are in chat you said Ethan
said wiping is optional I I got a
[__] you cannot slander me in my own
show that was liver King how dare you
put those words in my mouth wiping is
not optional shame on you stop it
if I'm that cop I'm letting his wife
wiping is not optional even for felons
shame on you
can I get I'll get I want the rest of
these officers badge numbers you said
there's three
but do me a favor don't make this turn
into any support okay I'm not I know I
know I'm not trying to I'm not forced
I'm not I'm not trying to I'm not trying
to get involved it's like a whole on
damn conversation
just chilling with his pants down
that's why it's just so absurd that I
like my my instinct tells me but look
it's be skeptical but I I can't really
look at the AM PM 711 shelf here it's
like right yeah it seems very authentic
it seems like
and that seems like real police gear and
stuff I don't know he's going to respond
and be like I'll explain it here in my
new music
right yeah
I just wanted I just want to write my
ass
wait okay
why'd you pull that up
why did you even pull that up because
that was a conversation you had at one
point was wiping being I think I found
the clip I definitely don't think it's
optional what wow I definitely found a
clip wow they found I'm sorry
I think I remember the conversations
maybe you did with your but it must be a
bad day you got [__] no no no no no
the conversation was about like
life or death I don't know it was like
dream let's find out was it really it
sounds like you just got around though
all right let's go back
let's see what this whole conversation's
about that's the clip go look for the
clip
look at my fat ass
don't what do you understand
that you're saying I get what you're
saying wiping is optional I'm just
wondering if wait what I know I don't
believe that so there needs to be some
more content can you let it if you just
let it go for like a month or two and
you develop some sort of skin rash and
then that got infected from all the
fecal matter in the area
I think we were talking about like in a
survival situation
would you die if you didn't wipe
would you die if you didn't wipe your
ass
not probably not right let me go back
more you know that
Sam's on Tick Tock dude Sam's tick
tock's fire I didn't know she was on
Twitter tweets are [__] up
you had this Banger the other day this
wasn't that long ago
[__] it's crazy
this was a year it was a year ago yeah
wow they've been working out for a long
time now
stop
she's talking about
that is actually no information to me
yes I am social media rules
[Applause]
okay born to [__] forced to wipe this is
what started it all right
right but let's rehash this okay now I
remember the conversation now
okay because I feel like I need to
defend myself
so I'm being exposed now that's deep
three you don't have to what wiping is
definitely an optional activity just for
the record well they're saying life
doesn't wow
I don't know man I wasn't like you
shouldn't wife it was like
he says born to [__] forced to wipe
who's forcing you to wipe you cannot
wipe your ass and like go about your
business you can
it's not like physically impossible but
you have to wait this is the society
says we must wipe our ass
this guy was forced not to wipe
so opposite I also say that we should do
that to what I also say we should do
that what yeah well I think we should
too hundo P I think so too but see now
I'm being defense you're not walking
around with like you're just saying you
have to [__] you don't have to wipe you
can walk around with the shitty [__]
my dogs do it every day why would a
human being want to do that
I'm just saying it's optional bro
you seem pretty passionate about this I
don't know man like you're pretty you
guys are missing the Nuance of my point
you should have been more uh nuanced
when making the point then I do I am
well you might you might get some
comments like
I don't you could develop some sort of
rash like right expected I think I don't
know wiping is uh is totally options
like back in the day when we were Hunter
gathers that we wiped our asses hell no
we just squatted that's true you just
dropped yourself
this is literally covered ground
no I need to understand what I'm saying
because
no stop it love well we were talking
about a nature setting
and in nature center gatherers I see the
I see the connection yeah yeah wipe yeah
I feel like they would yeah people are
demanding the apology you tell me
there's people cruising around I smelled
people man they didn't wipe their ass I
never caught a whiff of some of these
people out there man I I have a friend
that's a pretty bad wiper so to explain
all these you got to teach them bro okay
I did not explain myself well in that
moment
I sincerely apologize for
spreading the opinion that you should
not wipe I'm pro-wipe
I am very pro-wife pro-life pro-life you
say wife or wife pro-choice white
pro-life Pro wife
[Music]
when I was fat fat man bad you need to
you need to do a man good you need to
apologize to Miriam
okay Miriam I do apologize to you
I do think like technically if you get
down to the Brass tax you were wrong
but I you do deserve an apology because
I came so verbally after you
but you guys know what I'm saying it's
not like breathing is you're forced to
breathe
I already I I made my point in that
original clip I think that if you didn't
wipe your ass at all you would get an
infection that without treatment could
probably okay so that's an interesting
Counterpoint that at least addresses my
actual argument Dan says if you don't
wipe you will die and that's it that is
interesting let me Google that
can we ask GPT for
oh now you're talking I'm gonna have to
ask Jeep I know you guys some of y'all
thought it was boring but there's
certain instances
where it is really good
um
wait what the [__] can you get sick or
die if you don't wipe make sure it's
four after four defecating
are you asking the smart one look at
that clip
deficating for an extension no it's
totally optional wiping optional why
don't you why don't you Google it can
you okay all right all right history
repeats itself
but this time we have chat GPT
that's true
uh-huh
what's taking you so long Dan not
getting answers you want no no
um here we go
put it on screen so I know you're not
this is four
uh uh you gotta you gotta set it to four
at the top
okay so it says yes it's possible get
sick or die if you don't wipe for an
extended period of time
billing to wipe can lead fecal matter
and bacteria around your anus which can
lead to infections such as anal absences
hemorrhoids urinary tract infections
your rare cases untreated infections can
lead to Serious conditions like sepsis
eventually life-threatening infection
so there you go there you go wiping is
mandatory mandatory for to live and
there we have the answer
but at least it addresses my actual
point which I'm not saying don't wipe
okay
okay all right thank you
[Music]
because what she says in the chat wiping
is option Ethan thinks wiping is
optional that sounds like I'm okay
walking around with [__] in my ass
I'm a I'ma eat your ass and I just want
to make it very clear
I don't wipe my ass bro that that is not
my official stance okay
I'm glad we clarified that
what the [__] is going on with this I'm
trying to go to not to speak
what are you trying to do I'm trying to
go to the [__] chat GP here God damn
did they make it so hard to click your
GPT
I'm a [__] Savage you gotta do it you
gotta do it
can you um okay anyway so okay we're
making progress here
I just want to log in here and it's I
don't think I'm logged into the yeah I'm
not uh it was logged in I want to log
into the um
can you send me the password
I'm just gonna log in real fast sorry
guys
uh give me a minute
so we got uh
the one we used for the show uh doesn't
have the paid thing though well give me
the page password you it's your you said
you bought it no I it's the Dan it's
your email oh okay you want to use mine
yeah
I mean you you're using the show card
for that right no I I just got it for
myself
yeah but you just send it to you
whatever you can use it oh I meant for
you to pay for it from the show well
from yourself I'll change it to your
card yeah do that okay
I've been using it been at home stealing
Dan's [__] I thought I paid for it
thank you
there you go thank you hey why is it
what are people asking for a poll where
everyone agrees that you should wipe
there's no pull necessary no I think we
closed the case on this one yeah what
what is the point of the poll okay here
I'm gonna ask I love G I can't I guys I
love this [__]
it's so good it's so fun
well
I die if I don't wipe you gotta just be
real with it
I'm not a medical professioner I know
that
not wiping after using toilet can lead
to poor hygiene but it's unlikely to
cause death
so directly
so it's optional let me ask you it
sounds like it's still possible let me
ask it is wiping optional let's see what
it does with that okay
to death
is wiping optional yeah let's see let's
see it's got a lot to say all right I'm
stopping his wiping optional while there
are no strict rules on whether you or
not you must wipe maintaining so he's
talking about hygiene
says there's a common practice to remove
the poop
this helps prevent spread of germs okay
which okay minimizes odors if you put
not to use the toilet then you know get
yourself a bidet sounds like but he says
I think wiping is optional we asked the
smarter version
is wiping optional okay but here so okay
wait so if you had to say yes or no to
it being optional which
one is more accurate
to say
if I had to choose between yes or no I
would say yes that is more accurate
oh oh oh it's more out well is it
optional yes if I had to choose between
yes or no regarding weather wiping is
optional I would have to say that okay
but at a certain point is it optional
stay alive no
he said no I was wrong no he said I
would say that it's more Accolade to say
no
I thought I said oh that's the inside
the office I almost got you though
almost convinced you
if I had to choosing yes or no
whether wiping is optional I would say
that it is more accurate to say no
okay well who are you to tell me all
right chat gbt has never wiped you've
never watched that's true okay I don't
want to get into the chat should be too
rabbit hole but there's another cool
plug there's another cool plugin for
that where you can make it into like a
Siri you can basically make it so it
listens to your voice instead oh that's
interesting you don't have to write
anything oh God thank God can I just
read my thoughts can I just think for me
just tell me what to think
um
let's see excuse me came right out
oh These Guys these guys at a university
pushed the disabled person's wheelchair
down the stairs it's this video is
insane it's insane it's like it's insane
it's rare you get to see like the
thought process on someone's face as
they're just doing something so
unbelievably stupid and cruel actual
Apes yeah exactly they're just like
monkeys like whoa look at this Kyle
marks thank you for the gift we love you
talking Bean thank you for the gift look
at all these gifted holy [__] get a
little little subby run
so this person said these are I guess uh
they're jocks
I think there's from some sports team
they were hockey players yeah from mert
murky Hurst Mercyhurst oh mercy Lord
Mercy Mercy Lord so here they are
see a wheelchair and they say [__] this
person I guess the person
left it there to go down the stairs and
use the restroom that's what I heard as
well yeah
so here they are having a good old time
a couple of dudes a couple of jocks
what's up bro what's up bro
yo I just want to know
yo it's good to see you bro I'm so glad
you made it out yeah the chair is
ominously sitting there this dude this
is the main instigator he's like yo
what's yo there ain't no [__]
disabled people here are there look at
this dude
he's like yo what the [__] is that thing
is this yours what the [__] these guys
didn't even notice it until that guy
pointed out
oh let me sitting it oh [__]
idiot oh look I can't walk imagine being
imagine being an idiot and using this
yeah we should do what oh my God okay so
that was like a three-way collaboration
they all couldn't participate in that
wheelchairs are super expensive by the
way
yeah and I mean I just did
I have to imagine to somebody who uses
it every day of their life it's so
that's like so violating you know I'm
like right
it's very personal yeah it's like you're
that's your whole like ability to get
around the world right there I mean also
you're disabled like you've been dealt
kind of a rough hand you're coping
you're doing your best and these [__]
abled-bodied jock ass [__]
who have their whole life ahead of them
who probably have Rich ass parents who
are paying their way through college I
guess the the one of them's dad was a is
a famous uh hockey player like an NHL
joke executive he's the GM for the
Philadelphia Flyers
that's horrible yeah horrible press and
the wheelchair uh the person whose
wheelchair was is a W uh double amputee
oh my God
a double amputee
how do you come back from here just why
they they again did they have anything
to say for themselves it was just like
it not really not that there really is
anything to say but it's just so stupid
like the video like I'm laughing but
it's just because it's the majority of
it why why well Erie Pennsylvania the
county where the school is they charged
them so um they got charged for a crime
yeah that's awesome
[Music]
let's see well they posted the video
uh three different statements regarding
the investigation the athletes were
placed on suspension
she also tweeted she knows the person
whose wheelchair it was and they would
like to remain anonymous there's a
GoFundMe created to help raise money for
a new wheelchair it only has eight
thousand dollars well let's how much is
a wheelchair
what the [__] ain't no more people give
me money to this
um
everybody's saying our stream is
stuttering a little bit right now
uh so sorry about that stand by I don't
see any
I don't see any issue at all on my end
actually you know I would I would
happily donate to this
but they're so like how do I know this
wasn't just some person who's like hey
I'm going to pretend to raise money for
them because this isn't them
yeah she posted a picture saying that
she's not going to take
um money she didn't want to take money
from the GoFundMe but she will use some
to fix her wheelchair
so in the next link yeah sure I don't
know that I should donate then yeah no
I'm not because I think there's a lot
oh here's a
if they explicitly said that they don't
want the money uh now I'm really
confused because she said if this is her
she didn't want to be involved
no no she's not the person that posted
the video
if that's a confusion all right I'm not
I'm not I'm not donating to this
if you need uh you know what I'm saying
um a lot of people are saying that it's
stuttering and many people in the chat
are saying they're not so it sounds like
it may
um
Maybe on YouTube side because I don't
see any drops on our we lost a lot of
viewers
yeah I wonder
what's going on
um I would suggest trying to refresh and
seeing that fixes the issue
because it doesn't appear to be anything
we can do about it unplug something and
plug it back in okay
wheelchairs are four to nine thousand
listen I would I would happily donate I
just don't want to give money to some
random person that doesn't go to her you
know
because that's what GoFundMe really I'm
seeing conflicting info on that love I'm
seeing manuals are from 500 to 2000 but
they can go up to as high as 30. so
thirty thousand thirty thousand oh for
uh power for a powered one yeah I could
see that
what dicks bro it's crazy
um the person that owned the wheelchair
came forward and posted a picture of
herself saying she does not want any of
the money from the GoFundMe
okay so let's not yeah Carson Brie has
since been charged with criminal
mischief
that's such a funny charge criminal
mischief fun and Whimsical Mischief
it's like a leprechaun what you charge a
leprechaun for
bring back that cold
your Mischief wait wait wait but the
leprechaun he didn't steal the gold the
whole idea is you steal the gold from
the leprechaun isn't that right
I'm rewriting history damn dude haven't
the leprechaun's gone through enough
oh the wheelchair was two thousand
dollars when uh purchase a year ago
okay specific wheelchair seems about
right
um would you be with me if I cheated
tick tock on weird
oh God this one's so painful let's take
a look
you would still be with me oh I saw okay
I saw this one on my page yeah you sent
it and no hate to them
because
um
they're not doing anything wrong they're
sweet people it just struck me as a
little bit
odd like I couldn't tell if they were
joking or serious
he they're having this hypothetical
conversation about
if you cheated if I cheated would you
stay
and she says no I would not
and then he starts crying
I'm with some [__] like I'm cheating
right it just it's just watch and tell
me what you guys think no no hate to
them they're very nice they've done
nothing wrong I'm just really curious
about this social setting here you would
still be with me if I cheated
one two three
so
would you be with me if I cheated she
said no strongly disagree which you know
Queen behavior of course he said
disagree not strongly so basically the
same answer I agree what no not strongly
I feel like for me I didn't but strongly
disagree because
she knows it's coming I could I don't
know
baby
sorry
hey I'm sorry I didn't mean to upset you
no it's okay
when you get upset because we don't no
one's gonna do that you know no I just
I just put disagree because I was
between disagree and agree
because I really couldn't find anyone
else like you honey
I was just mind [__] by that like I
couldn't tell if it was real or a joke
you guys thought it was real I guess
maybe it's real just but disagree
because I was between disagree and agree
um right
bro you need to like just
that's that's tough I don't know how you
can live your life like that
also also girl you just got the green
light to go [__] whoever you want
sneakers being like yes sir another
layer of this is you sent this in the
chat and I watched it and I was cringing
pretty bad but I was also like you know
they're like 14 15. no they're not
well they're adults yeah no I found that
out later they're in their late 20s oh
late one no no 24 and 25. okay
they met over uh don't they both look
like teenagers like both of them like
have like I figured they were 20. he's
like he's got teenage baby faces that
guy's 25.
but like he's like well the fact that
you said you would even leave me breaks
my heart it's like well
you cheated
you too like they both yeah you wrote
this they both wrote that I can never
leave you baby I I just I was stunned by
it I just I was like what the [__] and I
had so many views too I don't know if
it's people having the same reaction as
me
like I'm cheating right or if people
think it's cute I don't know I know
comments definitely think it's cute at
least on YouTube yeah I know exactly how
he feels putting so much love into
somebody and then not wanting them to be
gone even though they broke your heart
if it didn't happen she didn't cheat on
you it's like a stupid little [__]
game
it's a stupid [__] game and you're
crying it's just like I don't know you
cannot live your life through going
through this world being that sensitive
well you know what
actually when I was watching I was like
damn like I'm so happy for him that he
found a partner that is like wants to be
so sensitive you know what I mean like
she seems she seems like you know she's
a beautiful a beautiful match to him you
know what I mean you know what I thought
I thought God forbid they play [__] Mary
kill because this guy's gonna jump out
the window
I killed myself three times because you
would even conduct or answer that
question they seem to be happily in a
relationship I think that's awesome
they're they're married apparently I'm
saying okay they're married we love that
for them this comment says the baby talk
actually means that they are in a safe
place and able to let their inner child
free with each other yeah but it's on
Tick Tock yeah it's on they're recorded
it and put it on the line that's how
they met that's how they they fell in
love it was via tick tock
they got the tick tock brain oh goody
I'm happy for them you know I love I
love love
is love and I love love right we love
love we all love love I love pizza and I
love people I love you guys and I love
people
so I don't know it's just I was like wow
there's people that like right she likes
it
but I
I don't know I just don't know you know
I just that's are these I just wonder
are these the people that get mad at me
every day
I just put disagree because I was
between three like they've been watching
the show for five years and they're like
he crossed the line today
thank you
you really crossed the line easy tiger
you know I just I don't know but I God
bless them obviously no hate just
fascinated that's it
they have five million followers what
the [__] they need my approval for damn
five million mm-hmm and they have 700
000 Subs on YouTube too okay so love is
really I was real love is real and love
loves love love love love how do you
what do you think about love love
yeah I love it love loves love [__] yeah
dude
and I love love and I love that love
loves love
I love that too I love that do you love
love love love that I love love love I
love that love loves love and love loves
that I love love
beautiful right and I love it
[Music]
every time someone says love no I get or
especially when you say like love like
like just expressing that you like
something I'm like
I do that a lot I'm so sorry you do
you better get used to it because you
come into America boy like Eddie Murphy
yeah I'm going to get used to it so by
the way I uh during that put up a poll
asking how much of the people watching
were having buffering issues and 23 of
the audience was having problems so
interesting that kind of points me
towards uh maybe there's a regional
internet issue or something the Chinese
they're in the wild they're they're in
the wires it's retaliation for The Tick
Tock man I mean this comment is the fact
he cried is a true fact he really loves
her I I don't disagree I mean I don't
think if he didn't cry doesn't mean he
doesn't love her either I mean I don't I
just does anyone think that like you can
be too sensitive yeah
right yeah I mean again when you first
sent it and I thought they were 14 I was
just like oh this is this is what young
people who are in their first
relationship this is like you know sort
of the love love awkwardness that you
have to uh get yourself through but then
uh finding out that they were that old
but I don't know maybe this is still
their first relationship who the [__]
now I don't know maybe I put it another
way you're a bunch of [__]
[Laughter]
can can I be too emotionally
uh [__] this who cares I'm not this
isn't a good question for you robot
dumbass robot
doesn't understand feelings
okay well we love them
sir
we sure do love them love okay love
here's a clip about dog chiropractors
and now that we have the medical experts
at gbt I want to ask do chiropractors
does it actually work is there medical
evidence I did not [__] myself
their medical
uh evidence that suggests that Kai
Chiropractic chiropractors
can provide long-term
permanent
improvements Donnie and Health and Pain
Management is that right is that a good
is that good well said oh sure you can
start there
Chiropractic Care is a healthcare
professional focus on diet I know what
it is
oh my God you're trying too hard there
is evidence suggesting the chiropractor
can provide short-term relief which we
knew that
however the long-term effects of
chiropractic care and its role in
providing permanent improvements in
Health and Pain Management are still a
topic of research and debate
some Studies have found that
chiropractic care can lead to modest
improvements
while other Studies have found little to
no difference compared to other
treatments or no treatment at all the
effectiveness of chiropractor Carrick
could also vary depending on the
individual
so
that's then maybe he's hedging his
juries out he's hedging his bet Drew's
out
he's hedging his Bat
he's fit he's sitting on the fence with
that one
okay well what about dog Chiropractic
well that's we should watch the videos
first
what about
dogs
[Music]
chiropra Chiropractic
he'll figure it out
canine Chiropractic Care
um
yeah yeah we know what it is
blah blah blah blah blah practitioners
are usually veterinarians or
chiropractors
who have receive specialized training
okay shut up you're so dumb telling me
what it is so vanilla dude
there's anecdotal evidence that means no
evidence
that anecdotal evidence means someone
being like yeah I think it helped
the dog the dog said it was like the dog
said yeah I feel great so here let's
talk about this robot so this guy here
is a
animal Chiropractic chiropractor the
[__]
is there volume
yeah okay
you [__] kidding me
oh my god dude why did you do that to
that poor dog
this is hard to watch that was that's it
don't do that right
it's
he doesn't know what he's doing he
literally just closed it like a sandwich
like an accordion to that dog
played him like an accordion
there's no way that's doing [__] here's
another one dog chiropractors
this is the same guy
dude hear this position you gotta be
kidding me putting the [__] dog in a
full nelson why is he doesn't have
shoulder blades like we do
[Music]
what happened there
he's just stretching him let's stretch
them out it's just a zombie I hate it
these Germans dude
I was like surprised how compliant these
are these thought I was thinking these
dogs are so chill my dogs would not be
[__] cool with that Shredder would go
for the kill they must give him some
type of sedative
that is a hundred percent what's
happening they must now
this man thinks because he can do
Chiropractic on dogs now he could do it
on horses
the anatomy of every animal he's this is
a total fraud you can't just walk around
cracking Bones on different animals just
cracking
another [__] crackle horse
[Music]
he seems to love it
okay this is [__] this guy dude why the
[__] is this guy not banned off at tick
tock
you get banned and we got this guy
[__] putting the dog in a full nelson
look at this cat
what the [__]
it's the same guy everywhere
okay dude bro what you better not touch
my [__] cat
don't let this man around your animals
they 100 give them sedative 100 yeah for
cats and like there's no cat that
doesn't it's either that consider that
or he's adding the sound effects
yeah
oh I hate him I hate him
I hate this man
but see do you see what I'm saying like
because dog chiropracty has the same
validity as human Chiropractic
just cracking the bones it's no
different
so if this looks silly to you
yeah you should maybe question
if you should be doing that to a person
right yeah I know I think that's fair
good
you are such a weirdo stop it weirdo bro
weirdo you're [__] weirdo bro
I hate it
hate it
hate hate hate hate hate hate it thank
you Derek runts
the runs work
runs
um
we've pretty much gone over everything
so
um we're at a
247 right now so we're right around
coming up on the three hour mark if you
want to run it up that's it so I need to
I need to address the title
oh [__] we never did talk about that or
distract them for a second
no no no no no well y'all don't want to
talk about 9 11. wow you just launched
right into it
well you don't want to hear about 9 11.
it's all my head plays over and over
again I couldn't stop saying it last
week I finally got rid of it
[Music]
no no no no no you know well yeah
hey um
Donald Trump might get arrested tomorrow
morning that's going to be [__]
hilarious if that happens anybody see
that they're like setting up uh
barricades
no no no no that's good exactly Zach
that is insane you always impress me
thank you thank you wow well done
there I think this is it are we suiting
up tomorrow
like Hassan I heard he's gonna wear a
suit tomorrow wear a suit yeah for a
stream
that's funny we're not live tomorrow so
I guess not are we not oh
the hill [__] where's the [__]
video idiot here we go
this is what's going on in Manhattan so
yeah they're getting this guy for uh
paying off a porn star that he cheated
on his wife with
instead of you know all of the various
horrible
things that he's done that are much
worse than that but whatever
um well we'll see we'll see what happens
I mean like what
what is gonna happen okay they arrest
them well New York is a no what is it no
Bail no cash bail state is that true
uh I think that that just means that
they don't I think I mean I I'm sure
they're not going to hold him right
they're not going to be stuck in jail
right he's just gonna get like printed
and all the usual [__] no purp walking
probably the question is well they put
them in handcuffs or not I'm guessing no
right I feel like they're already
worried about the Optics of uh arresting
the President right uh enough that
putting them in handcuffs might not be a
good move
but uh I don't know I don't know I
really didn't think
anything would ever happen to him
to be perfectly Frank I was way more
cynical about that so um not you know
not story I don't know having your
supporters stormed the capital but you
know paying off a porn star yeah yeah it
was another storm that got him am I
right yo yo
hey B
[Music]
this is hard to watch move on says
Charlie okay I'm sorry I'm sorry it's
not working for you Charlie it's all for
you Charlie it's all we do it all for
you Charlie
um what are you doing over there I've
been typing for
yes okay I'm gonna go to the bathroom
here's what happened go ahead no [__]
hold on hold on okay
all right
his mind is merging with the machine
yes
I like this view she is into it
yeah this is slow and Jazzy is this a
new one
this is a new one I like it
makes me think of a warm Autumn night
oh yeah you're listening to H3 podcast
95.5
[Music]
this is like the typing meme
this is like uh slow Beats study food
where did he go
where did my boss go I just I just I
wanted to Riff on the on the radio thing
and I was like I just Googled jazz
player names for some funny names the
first one is Cannonball Adderley yeah
Cannonball Adderley coming up on the top
of the hour that's a real dude we got a
Wes Montgomery over here Cal Farland it
looks cool it looks cool Cannonball
Cannonball all right oh yeah and his
brother Nat Adderley matters is that his
government name or is Cannonball his
first name or is that early his first
name what is it uh is uh no his name is
Julian no Julian
[Music]
I'm getting nervous how intensely
what is he cooking he's lost he said he
had to go to the bathroom too he's
holding all right I'm gonna go to the
bathroom here's what happened on Friday
um this is what happened
you want to narrate it uh Dan I really
have to go to the bathroom I'm scared
what you've done no here this is what
happened
can you zoom in on whatever it is you're
trying to I haven't seen it yet
this is what happened
um this is what verbatim
[Music]
okay
Dan do you want to narrative
sorry I was uh answering uh ELO and
something uh okay once upon a time there
lived a man named Ethan Ethan was a
hard-working individual but he sometimes
makes poor decisions one evening after a
long day at work he decided to unwind at
the local pub after a few drinks Ethan
made the mistake of getting behind the
wheel and driving home
as Ethan drove along the dimly lit Road
he noticed that the flashing lights of a
police car in his rearview mirror
anxiety gripped him as he realized he
was about to be pulled over for driving
under the influence officer Gruff
known as known for his aggressive
demeanor not Gruff stepped out of the
police car and approached Ethan's
vehicle Ethan could see the stern
expression on the officer's face as he
tapped on the window reluctantly Ethan
rolled it down
I need to share your license
registration said officer Gruff
oh officer Gruff barked actually
even fumbled nervously with his wallet
producing the documents as quickly as
possible as the officer turned in the
car to run Ethan's information Ethan
couldn't help but feel a mix of fear and
regret
the officer's hostile manner only added
to the tension of the situation
officer Gruff came back to Ethan's
window his face red with anger sir I
have a reason to believe that you've
been driving Under the Influence please
step out of the car he ordered
Ethan complied his legs shaking as he
emerged from the vehicle the officer
began to conduct a field sobriety test
but Ethan struggled to maintain his
balance it was apparent that he was
intoxicated
suddenly amidst the tension officer
Gruff accidentally let out a loud fart
the smell was repugnant and filled the
air adding a layer of humiliation to the
already tense situation
Ethan couldn't help but notice that
that's fine there's real audio captured
from it you couldn't help but notice the
officer's discomfort following the fart
he began to suspect that the officer
might have had an accident in his pants
as the officer continued to arrest him
Ethan carefully observed the cop's
behavior and appearance for any signs of
mishap
you noticed strange bulkiness around the
officer's pants and the way he seemed to
be moving more gingerly than before the
smell and appearance of a large mass in
his pants and the cops movements all
pointed towards the possibility that the
officer had indeed
pooped his pants
as officer Gruff roughly handcuffed ooh
looking a little spicy now
you roll it up uh it's getting blocked a
little bit
officer officer Griff roughly handcuffed
Ethan and escorted him to the police car
even couldn't help but feel a strange
sense of vindication in his mind he was
almost certain that the aggressive cough
had experienced an embarrassing accident
despite this Ethan knew his own poor
decision that led to his arrest and he
vowed to learn from his mistake and
never drink and drive again the memory
of the Hostile officer and the
unpleasant smell during his arrest would
serve as a constant reminder of the
consequences of poor decisions
wow I'm glad you learned your lesson
that's what happened I'm glad you
learned your lesson uh there it is the
question is
did you wipe
I'll ask the question is did the officer
wipe it is optional after all
oh stop it you dumbass bot [__] idiot
bro it's a fictional no it's just a
simple question bro no [__] dumbass no
[__] dumbass
[Laughter]
like we didn't know that
all right
you're disappointing me
so Ela wants to call in and share some
kind of news with us uh yeah I sent her
the zoom link so there's something about
the pregnancy I understand I don't know
what it is
you're so good at surprises oh my God
I ca well did you really not like she
she I she told me on the thing but she
could tell she could call in
that's crazy hmm
so what are we waiting for for her to
call in okay
standing by
big news pretty cool how the bot can
write a story so fast yeah the story was
boring as [__] though I'm not gonna lie
I got through it but it was terrible
wait I liked it I think it was a good
story Jesus
[Music]
said I should have forgot I wrote it to
you
well that's okay you can still call in
okay she's in the lobby letting her in
I got big news oh boy
Ela is calling in with big news oh boy
big news oh boy
oh boy big news
okay so you got the results from the
doctor
yes bleed us up what it what results is
it you're getting this is the result of
them taking out the eggs we did the eggs
retrieval and then
um you start with a lot but then it goes
down a lot to a small number in the end
and where we've been waiting to hear how
many
they tell you about the good ones
they're you know like they have a rating
system and it's the ones that are like A
and B rating which is like we have we
have viable eggs that have been
fertilized successfully and would be
yeah it would have the best chance of
being a successful pregnancy yeah when
it's placed back inside of you yes okay
okay
so we got seven which is a lot
that's awesome that's like a lot yeah
and then I was like okay and I've been
waiting to hear the gender the you know
the sex is it a boy or a girl
and she's like okay so out of the seven
you have six boys and one girl oh my God
what is what are the odds I told you I
said we will they're all gonna be boys I
can't believe it they really are what
are the odds like if you no legitimately
like would that be uh
or whatever with the exclamation point
oh yeah so but so dude there's no way we
would have had a girl unless you went
this route you could have a really okay
we'd never get a girl
so did she tell you did she tell you the
rating on the eggs she said they're all
beautiful they're all beautiful eggs
gorgeous I believe that
holy [__] dude that girl is seriously a
miracle yeah so she said so are you
gonna go for a boy or a girl so I was
like obviously we're going for the one
girl
so she said okay so because you're gonna
go for the one girl I'm gonna do a
practice cycle where we give you all the
medication and we do everything and we
don't actually put anything inside just
to see that it all works
and then we're gonna do the actual cycle
after that
because she wants to make sure that our
one girl is able to yeah to hold through
yeah so it's just you multiply a half
because because it's 50 50. yeah however
many times in a row so six so a half six
times is one sixty fourth so there's a
one in 64 chance of you having oh that's
not as rare it's not like astronomical
but it's still very small it's still a
very small chance dude it's all boys who
determines the gender me or you
uh isn't it new I think that's the guy
who does yeah I think it's up today I
just got boys swimming in here yeah I
think I'm Alpha as [__] I'm like
traditional that's crazy I don't even I
can't even have girls
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it says men determine the sex of a baby
depending on whether their sperm is
carrying an X or a y x is boy right no
wise boy [__] that's B that's more beta
a letter
because it has less lines
definitely with 37 feet of cement
posting oh God
dude so okay we got a girl uh but uh if
it if that egg doesn't stick and then it
wasn't meant to be then you got boy you
got it
dude that's crazy so many boys
crazy
girl oh my God it's a girl that's what
she's gonna say you're gonna be like
it's a girl
it's a girl girl well that's exciting
I'm glad I'm glad you guys got the one I
genuinely thought
okay that's so crazy because actually
I guess I can say this we were thinking
about having two girls
but that's not even an option not even
an option
holy crap dude
I thought there'd be more than one but
okay there it is oh boy
[Music]
[Applause]
if you count the chances of uh
um
Bruce and teddy as well
it's really you're shooting flip again
twice it's eight eight boys to one girl
fertilization
oh boy oh boy
that's crazy
well I love my boys
yeah
the best that's a lot though that's a
lot of boy Power
and then what are you eating
tamales oh Frozen one
you're not making any dinner plans
without me are you wait we're going out
tonight we're going out today oh we are
forgot that's fun we're going out to
dinner with Theodore tonight
it's my fave I love going out with with
Teddy he has so much fun
we're going to a steakhouse he loves
steak too it's gonna be fun I'm excited
it's inappropriate
I love uh okay
all right I think you're the one that
has the boy curse
well it's you because you're the girl
though you're like one girl in a
I
do love my boys so
it's all good
oh you want should I should I show you
how Ela popped off on Instagram
no why
were you guys talking about before I
don't know 170
000 that's crazy
good for you dude
what's going on I can't see because the
you can't see because it's
hot I see that's what's happening it got
a lot of likes
people are loved loving
I love I know you looks hot as [__] I've
been I've been saying that you know
he's fine as hell it's a new year
he's fine you're as hell
all right I'm gonna come home right now
oh really yeah we're done we're done
yeah we're done we're just wrapping it
up do you want to ask me anything or the
crew anything oh it's the show
fine
I forgot to plug Teddy fresh because we
didn't have sponsors today
uh Jimmy um we did the vote on uh on
Jimmy if he's allowed to come to the
studio on Wednesday or not and he
actually
oh my God so our idea for Wednesday is
to try to put him through unpleasant
experience make him regret yeah
to eat the fika fish you're never gonna
make him work also to look at the
prolapse video
yeah he'll do it all again and again and
again
well then well that'll be interesting
won't it
by the way so Teddy fresh guys there's
all kinds of fun stuff teddyfresh.com
this one was made in the USA
laser focus on your goals I love this
one
nice stay motivated
today motivated with Teddy fresh
laser focused on your goals that's right
coming back to teddyfresh.com what else
we got
wash denim safety pin shirt we just was
this a restock or a fresh one
this is a new one this is a brand new
denim safety bed shirt
wow look at that all right
what about a skeleton bear and tarja
fantastic I think it's only sold our
internet [__] up or is our website
[__] up
all right
that'll be your that's gonna be you
could be
this is so uh they're still sizes small
medium large XL 2XL
very little of them
this one's great love this one you know
there's so much check it out it's
teddyfresh.com
yes
oh I need to get this piece I don't have
this one
Lena can you get me this one
oh yeah sold out the 2XL is gone
Elena's there with you it's all gone
holy [__]
[__] you guys want anything you see
anything you want
us we already got our stuff we're we're
hooked up what'd you guys get anything
anything uh yeah I got the uh button up
button-down shirt
um the uh no no the colorful one oh this
one yeah I love that shirt oh hell fits
great on me I mean it's I knew you'd
love that one that one that one is for
you yeah thank you yeah wore it this
weekend when I was in Palm Springs so
any comments yeah everyone loved it
everywhere I went um
it was really fun [__] amazing shirt
I'm like thank you would you go out with
the pants also or is that too much for
you I would you would do it I think in
the summertime yeah I think it's the
summer it's a summer Vibe do I have
these shorts I would like these shorts
I love the melting bear once oh oh yeah
love is wearing it
yeah I love how that one came out do we
have one for love
oh you're wearing it okay perfect that
was fast I got both a hoodie and and the
show
thank you
now there's a lot of good stuff on the
website right now actually
this is my new favorite Hat by the way
the which one the one oh really yeah oh
that one's great I love it I'm very very
picky about hats tonight I did this one
okay yeah I like that one it's good
that's good to know I've been wearing
this jacket every day Queen thank you
hey it's the is the big collab next
month the one that I'm not going to say
the name of but is that the one next
next month
oh yeah have a really fun one next month
Sam knows what it is she was working on
it I will not say but it is awesome yeah
it came out so excited we can say that
yeah the set looks awesome in the photos
came out so nice looking
so there it is uh Last Chance by the way
too Teddy first dog if you go to the
last chance tab deep discounts
for example Rick and Morty swag
you have to mention it every time which
you cannot wear outside
you have to mention that you can wear it
in your room you can wear it in your
house nobody's there just kind of throw
it out there everything as long as
nobody's there you can wear it in your
house chocolate mocha you know Collard
cream yeah they're all different flavors
but there's not oh there's this one yeah
this one you could wear it's not overtly
Rick and Morty could get away with that
crazy huh
all right I'll see you in a little bit I
all right thank you
Mother of Dragons
[Applause]
you should name if you guys have a
daughter you should name her Khaleesi oh
God I hate that man
[Music]
that was a popular name
Khaleesi
Khaleesi Daenerys
yeah yeah
all right well guys thanks so much for
watching tomorrow's for the members
oh wait do I have anything tomorrow Lena
or she's not here I keep forgetting not
here
um do I have a thing tomorrow nothing on
my calendar
but that may not be true
[Music]
but we'll be there for the members
regardless
because that's what it is our beautiful
members I love you
beautiful members I love love
I love
our beautiful members
[Music]
that's why we'll be doing a special
podcast just for you guys
just us
we got the music playing
John's John says this episode was weak
not gonna lie Sean
Sorensen says this episode was weak
better luck next time guys [__] you John
get the [__] out dude suck my dick how
about that this episode was we
did we spice it up enough right now John
John you [__] [__] yeah man dumbass
[__] you John
John idiot John and Josh should go
[__] be besties you know what's
another name for the [__] the John
got him oh sheesh sorry John I caught my
deep and zero apologies to John who was
not entertained today is my with sincere
regret I am mourning I announce
that
I I don't know if I'll be able to do the
show tomorrow
I'm devastated and we need to obviously
put more work in to Preparing and if we
can possibly get John's contact info so
that we can have him pre-screen the
content before we air it I feel like
that's a fair
way of handling this because it I need
to make sure John is entertained above
and of all other considerations do you
guys think John pisses from his balls
probably
just do a private episode for him John
that's it we should do a roll call John
will do a special Zoom link for you and
we will do this show through we'll come
in at 5am so we can do it before and
then John you can give us notes before
we go live
our creative director John
because he
oh did he do is this him oh this is him
he said just spitting facts well I don't
know if he's lying because he didn't put
NGL at the end so oh he might be lying
yeah it might be lying he might be a
liar
he's just spitting fast that's been
facts you know well John I uh sorry we
disappointed you it is they can't all be
bangers you know we do make a lot of
content and to be honest with you on the
Monday episodes we have no time to
prepare so it's kind of a miracle that
we even have a show on Monday
that was always the intent of the show
yeah in fact if anything I feel like we
do too much prep
let's go back to doing no prep for
Monday maybe that'd be better for John
or maybe John's should do it if he
doesn't like it let's let's fly John out
John would you like to work for us let's
go to offering John I'd like to offer
you a lot of money he literally asked
that did you
he did he asked that before you said
that he said I'd love to to be honest
job application yeah no I I think he
might be a Wellspring of good ideas yes
John please send us your resume John
knows strong content okay email email I
want your credentials dude send John
John send us your resume yep it's
basically a yes but I just want to see
I think he might be Scandinavian his
last name is Scandinavian oh no so I
think his name is Joan
[Music]
John for the job all right the outro
music has played twice it just finished
the second throwback to 2020. all right
thank you guys and apologies to John uh
we will see you guys members tomorrow
Wednesday we'll be back with the Jimmy
Lee special which I'm actually looking
forward to now that I know we're gonna
make him suffer the whole time
uh but anyway shout out and apologies to
John thank you guys
thank you
[Music]